We're going to start in about 30 seconds if everyone will take their seats please.
Good evening everyone.
It is August 13th, 2026, 530 p.m.
We are met in the chambers of the Huntsville City Council in Huntsville, Alabama.
We welcome everyone who has joined us in the chambers this evening as well as those who
are joining us virtually.
We will begin our meeting as is our practice with an invocation that will be offered by
one of our Huntsville, Alabama police safety chaplains, Chaplain Rachel Harper, and she
will be followed by Pledge of Allegiance led by Councilmember David Little.
All who are able and wish to do so please stand for the invocation and the pledge.
Father, we thank you for this day and we thank you Father for the many blessings that you
have bestowed upon us.
We come to you with a grateful heart for what you've done for us as individuals but what
you've also done for us as a city.
Lord, we just ask for continued blessings in favor and Father, I ask for guidance tonight
over our City Council, over our Mayor, over our City Attorney as they take up the business
of the City, Lord.
And I just ask Father that you will give them divine wisdom and I pray protection over all.
We ask these things in your name, Lord.
Amen.
Thank you, Chaplain Harper.
Thank you, Mr. Little.
Councilmembers, you have the agenda before you.
Are there any changes or additions to be made to the agenda?
Hearing none, the agenda is approved.
You also have the minutes of the regular meeting of the City Council held on July 23rd, 2026.
Are there any changes or corrections to be made to the minutes?
Hearing none, the minutes are accepted as presented.
The Mayor has no special recognitions but Councilmembers do have several recognitions.
6A is resolution honoring Tony Terrell for excellence in broadcasting and community service.
Is there a motion?
Move to approve.
Second.
Motion from Ms. Watkins.
Second from Mr. Kling.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
I'm going to stop to make the presentation.
Thank you.
Mayor, would you like to join me down?
Good evening, everyone.
So I'm not sure if you all are familiar with WHRP.
We have someone we call our best girlfriend and her name is Tony Terrell.
Tony, will you join us up on the stage?
Thank you.
So what a lot of people don't know about Tony, you've been in this area now, what, 20 years?
But you've been in broadcast 42, 42 years in broadcast.
That is awesome.
But 20 years, she has been right here in Tennessee Valley.
I listen to her in the morning on my way to work.
She is so nice and friendly.
Her voice is just welcoming.
When you listen to her, you just feel like, oh, okay, I'm going to have a good day.
So she's not on the radio and she takes vacation.
I want to call her and say, can you just encourage me a little bit?
But whereas the city council and mayor of Huntsville, Alabama recognized Ms. Tony Terrell
for her outstanding 42-year career in radio broadcasting and her exceptional commitment
to informing, inspiring, and serving communities across the nation, including two decades of
service in the Tennessee Valley.
Whereas she began her professional career in early childhood development, Tony Terrell
pursued her passion for broadcasting by attending the Bailey School of Broadcasting in San Francisco,
California, graduating in 1984, earning her FCC license and launching a successful broadcasting
career that began with metro traffic control before advancing through radio stations in
California, Colorado, Texas, and ultimately Huntsville, Alabama.
Whereas since making Huntsville her home in 2006, Tony has become a trusted and familiar
voice throughout the Tennessee Valley, serving as the host of the At Work Network on WHRP
for 14 years before becoming the host of the popular Tony in the Morning show in 2021.
Where she continues to entertain, inform, and encourage listeners each weekday while
also hosting Saturday Morning Classics, a program that celebrates timeless music and
cherished memories.
Whereas Tony's talent and professionalism has earned national recognition through her
work with Westwood One's urban format, The Touch, her daily on more than 20 radio stations
across the country, as well as her hosting the Sunday Morning Inspirations and her role
as co-host of the Billboard and American Music Awards radio broadcast for Cumulus Radio
from Las Vegas and Los Angeles.
Whereas affectionately known as your best girlfriend, Tony Terrell has consistently
used her platform to serve others by leading the annual WHRP Coats and Cans for Kids campaign,
providing warm coats and food to families in need.
Tony, let me tell you, she does this every year, and every year, no child in the city
of Huntsville I know of does not have a coat.
And Tony does this faithfully, and we appreciate you for that.
And the support in St. June Radiothon and delivering critical information encouraging
during times of crisis, including the 1989 San Francisco earthquake, the 1992 Los Angeles
civil unrest, and the devastating 2011 tornadoes that impacted us here in town.
Whereas through her unwavering dedication to broadcasting community service and public
outreach, Tony has become a respected leader, trusted communicator, and compassionate advocate
whose positive influence has enriched the lives of countless residents throughout Huntsville,
the Tennessee valleys, and communities across the nation.
Now therefore, let it be resolved that the City Council and Mayor of Huntsville, Alabama
do hereby recognize and honor Tony Terrell for her remarkable career in broadcasting
and her steadfast commitment to community service.
The city and mayor extend their sincere appreciation for your dedication to informing, uplifting,
and serving the people of Huntsville and the Tennessee Valley for the last 20 years.
Thank you, Tony.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ms. Terrell, for all of your service in our community.
6B is a resolution honoring Huntsville's immigrant community.
Motion to approve.
Second.
Motion from Mr. Meredith, second from Ms. Watkins.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
Mr. Meredith, would you like to make the presentation?
Yes, ma'am.
Ms. Stewart and Ms. Jackie Scheipe, if you could come down and bring those that have
been delegated to come down with you.
Thank you.
Who's going to translate?
You need to be there.
Susan, why don't you come stand close by because you'll get an opportunity to speak.
So we're going to do it a little bit different this time.
Since this is an immigrant resolution, we will have a Spanish-speaking translator.
So whereas the City Council and mayor of Huntsville, Alabama, enjoy the benefits of a
dynamic immigrant population representing areas from every corner of the globe.
And whereas immigrants have made significant contributions to Huntsville's reputation as
a global leader in space exploration and scientific advancement through their work in research,
engineering, and innovation.
And whereas immigrants serving as doctors, nurses, medical professionals, and support
staff have been vital in establishing Huntsville as the leading medical center for North Alabama.
And whereas immigrants have established businesses, created jobs, worked in essential industries,
and contributed hundreds of millions of dollars each year to Huntsville's economy.
And whereas immigrants have contributed to the cultural diversity of Huntsville, enriching
the very vibrant fabric of our city.
And whereas immigrants have served in the United States Armed Forces in disproportionate
numbers, defending the nation with bravery and distinction.
And whereas the city of Huntsville values its immigrant community and seeks to promote
cooperative, peaceful existence and equality for the community.
Now therefore be it resolved that the City Council and Mayor of Huntsville, Alabama recognize
and celebrate the invaluable contributions of immigrants and encourages all residents
to embrace the significant role our immigrant community plays in strengthening and enriching
our city.
Thank you very much.
Susan, I'd like for you to have the first opportunity to give your comments.
I thought I'd be making this from behind the safety of the podium later, but here we go.
I'm Susan Stewart.
My address is on file.
Now I'm here to speak about the resolution honoring Huntsville's immigrant community.
I want to thank Councilmember Meredith for sponsoring this resolution, for listening
to and understanding the concerns of the immigrant community and their advocates.
And thank you to the Mayor and City Council for stating so clearly with this resolution
that Huntsville would not be what it is today were it not for the immigrants who have chosen
to make Huntsville their home today and for hundreds of years.
I'm humbled by the people I've met during the last year, representatives of immigrant
led organizations and individual members of the immigrant community who are speaking about
the needs of their community and who are taking concrete action to meet those needs and to
help keep their community safe.
I am grateful for my fellow advocates who have shown up here and elsewhere with passion
and a zeal for justice.
We will not forget that our city depends on the presence of contributions of people who
come from around the world, and I promise we will not stop advocating for their
constitutional rights and their safety.
Thank you so much, Councilmember Meredith.
You are very welcome.
Can you acknowledge our name?
Veronica Carney of Latino Hope and Advocacy has been our translator tonight at the last
minute.
She agreed to do this.
Thank you so much, Veronica.
Forgive my being remiss, but Mr. Mayor, if you would like to join us certainly for the
photo op, please come on up and be a part of this if you would like.
And then finally, I would like for Ms. Jackie Scheidt to comment.
Councilman Meredith, what an honor for myself, all who are up on the stage, and those in
the audience, because immigrants could not have successfully integrated into the community
if it wasn't for the entire village.
So we are so thankful.
I am the Chief Executive Officer for Global Ties Alabama, and for 61 years we have led
the effort not only to support immigrants, to resettle refugees, and to welcome
international visitors, delegations that are sent by the U.S. Department of State to this
community, and the citizen diplomats that are in this room that have supported each
of our visitors, international visitors.
It has been a blessing and a true reflection on our United States of America, which is
founded on the backs of immigrants.
There are a lot of organizations up here, but for the sake of time, we're just going
to say thank you very much for all that you do for the immigrant community.
I know we have had it translated into Spanish, but this proclamation, this resolution is
universal.
It is for immigrants, no matter where you have come from, you find yourself in Huntsville.
We want you to know that we appreciate all of your contributions and that this is for
you as well.
Thank you.
Thank you everyone.
We'll go on with the rest of our meeting now as everyone takes their seats.
6A is a resolution.
6A is a resolution honoring Colonel Erin Icke for her leadership and service to Redstone
Arsenal and the Huntsville community.
Move to approve.
Second.
Motion by Ms. Watkins, second by Mr. Little.
All in favor please indicate.
I.
Opposed.
The motion carries.
Microphone, Ms. Watkins.
I actually ask all the council members to join me with the mayor.
This is kind of a mayor to mayor meeting here.
Colonel Icke has been the mayor of Redstone Arsenal for the past three years, two years?
Two years.
And she is the one every day, once everybody gets into the arsenal and gets to work, they
become the eighth largest city in the state of Alabama, which is something to be said,
45,000 people working there.
Come on up, come on up.
And she is moving out of her garrison command post, moving over to space and missile defense
where we just had a big space and missile defense conference here.
Had 11,000 people who came in.
And she is going to be over there so we don't have to worry about our space or our missiles
or our defense, either one, because she will be taking care of that also after she leaves
as garrison commander.
But we have a proclamation there, a resolution.
It says whereas the city council and the mayor of Huntsville recognize Colonel Erin Icke
for her outstanding leadership and dedicated service as commander of Redstone garrison
and for making history as the first woman to hold the position in Redstone Arsenal's
85 year history.
And Colonel Icke did such a good job that she has another lady coming in right behind
her, another colonel coming in right behind her who is female also.
Okay, whereas Colonel Icke assumed command of Redstone Arsenal on August 1st, 2024 and
throughout her two year tour has led with wisdom, dedication and compassion.
And whereas during her tenure, Colonel Icke successfully navigated significant challenges
including budget restraints, hiring limitations, understaffed resources, particularly within
the security guard force.
We won't go too far into that.
And whereas a native of Windom, Minnesota, Colonel Icke began her military career when
she enlisted in the Minnesota National Guard in 1998 and has devoted her career to serving
our nation in both peace and war earning numerous military honors and awards.
Whereas Colonel Icke's leadership and service have made a lasting impact on Redstone Arsenal
and the greater Huntsville community strengthening the partnership between the arsenal and the
city.
And whereas Colonel Icke relinquishes command of the Redstone garrison on August 18th, 2026.
The city of Huntsville is pleased to recognize her remarkable tenure and is grateful that
she will continue serving the community in her next army assignment with the space and
missile defense command.
And now we've got the now therefore resolved.
But before I get to that, it's been, you have been a great partner, a great partner in
Huntsville's success, Huntsville's growth.
Space command came in and you took care of it.
Different agencies have had to grow and had to move around and you have taken care of it.
And we want to say thank you for doing such a great job at Redstone Arsenal.
And now therefore be it resolved that the city council and the mayor of the city of
Huntsville do recognize and honor Colonel Erin Icke for her historic leadership as the
first woman to serve as commander of Redstone garrison and for her exceptional service to
Redstone Arsenal, the United States Army and the Huntsville community and extend their
sincere appreciation for her dedication, compassion and continued service in our community.
And it's signed by all the council members and myself.
So that makes it a unanimous agreement, which is not easy for our Huntsville city council
to come up with.
Thank you so much.
And Colonel Icke made it through luncheon today without without shedding a tear.
So she did very well.
But I would love for you to give us some remarks.
Thank you very much, Mayor and to the entire city council.
Redstone Arsenal is what it is.
A phenomenal installation because of the surrounding community.
It wouldn't be what it is without the support from the community, the support from the leaders.
So I just want to say thank you very much in return.
It's been an honor working with all of you and hope that Redstone meets your expectations as well.
So thank you again.
Thank you.
Mr. Colonel Icke, Mr. Colonel Todd.
So glad you're staying.
Thank you.
It was quite something to attend Colonel Icke's luncheon today and to hear her staff talk about her with
tremendous respect for the work that she has done.
It's evident she is a great leader and we look forward to.
We're glad that her leadership gets to stay here in the community and that she has chosen to be part of district three.
Thank you for that.
Thank you again for being with us.
60 is a resolution honoring the low profile car club for its commitment to community and service.
Motion for Ms. Watkins seconded Mr. Little.
All in favor please indicate.
I oppose.
Mr. Watkins would you like to make that presentation.
Right here.
Mayor bad on to get you to get up one more time.
Can the members a low profile please come to the stage.
I don't know if any of you like antique cars classic cars.
These guys got anything you want to see.
And every year we call them to do the parades of the Huntsville High Homecoming Parade Jimmison Homecoming Parade and the back school parade.
And guess what.
They come without fear.
It's more.
They just didn't come up tonight.
How many years in your group.
They have 21.
But I think they got like 500 cars.
So I'm going to read this resolution.
One hundred percent.
They're nice to whereas the city council mayor of Huntsville recognized low profile club as longstanding organized nonprofit automotive organization that brings together many women who share a passion for classic customized and old school cars and trucks.
Whereas founded around 2007 the low profile car club has grown into a family oriented organization that promotes fellowship mutual support and a shared appreciation for automotive automotive culture throughout Huntsville and Tennessee Valley.
Whereas over the years low profile has involved in a shared his love of automobiles into an organization dedicated to giving back to the community which they do.
They give donations.
They come to the schools.
They volunteer.
Anytime I call them they show up and I know sometimes they might look at my number and be like what do she want now.
But the low profile club provides opportunities for its members to showcase their vehicles through car shows cruisers parades and other community events while using these gatherings as an opportunity to strengthen fellowship and positively engage the Huntsville community.
Whereas the members of low profile strive to be a beacon of integrity and service by fostering a family oriented and spiritual environment that encourages this member to support others and enhance the lives of others they encounter.
Whereas through its commitment to fellowship charitable service service youth mentorship and community involvement the low profile club has been able to support and enhance the lives of others they encounter.
Whereas through its commitment to fellowship charitable service service youth mentorship and community involvement the low profile car club has become a valued organization within the Huntsville community and continues to make a positive difference through its members and outreach.
Now therefore let it be resolved that the city council and mayor of Huntsville Alabama do hereby recognize and honor the low profile car club for its long standing commitment to fellowship community service youth mentorship and community involvement.
And I'm going to I'm going to let the president or whoever wants to speak but I'm going to challenge the mayor this year to come up out the fire truck mayor.
It's cooler to be in a low profile car.
They'll bring you right back to your destination.
Who's gonna speak.
Evening everyone.
We've been a part of Huntsville's 2007.
We do numerous
settings and programs and donations and
other activities in the community but
you know we do a lot of
services.
and other activities in the community,
but it's been a pleasure serving.
So this was an honor to be accepted tonight.
And this is our 19th year.
It's our anniversary this weekend,
so y'all welcome to come out.
We'll be at the Bob Harrison Center,
and we'll be at our clubhouse 2800 Jordan Lane,
Friday and Saturday at Bob Harrison.
So y'all more than welcome to come out and join us.
He forgot to say they have good food.
Thank you.
7A is the presentation
on the Paracycling World Championships.
The presentation will be given by Claire Aiello,
who is the Communications Director for the Chamber.
Claire, welcome.
Hello everyone.
Thank you so much, council, for having me.
I have a fun presentation for everyone here,
and I hope you'll enjoy it,
and I hope you will join us at the races,
September 4th through the 7th.
And I think this is very timely to follow the honor
that you just presented to the immigrant community,
because you will see many of your countries here competing.
So the dates are September 4th through the 7th
in Cummings Research Park.
We are very excited to welcome these athletes,
and we have a number of partners
who are helping us with this,
from financial support to infrastructure help,
police support, medical support.
It takes a lot to put these races on.
This is our fifth one we've done,
and it's taking, you know,
international community has noticed they're coming back,
because they had such a good experience
in 2023 for the World Cup.
We have 50 countries coming.
So far, the number has risen,
since I turned in my slideshow a few days ago,
Costa Rica jumped in,
but we have 50 countries coming.
Many of them are from South America.
We have many countries coming from Europe,
Japan, Mexico, Argentina, Brazil,
Team USA will be here, Ireland will be here.
So many of the countries that, you know,
the people in this room are from, you know,
whether it's your long time,
whether it's your grandparents were from there,
or you're from there,
you're gonna see your country's athletes competing here,
and it's gonna be special.
In two weeks, Great Britain is the first team to arrive,
and then most teams will arrive August 29th and 30th.
So that's two weeks from now, two and a half weeks.
They're gonna be staying in our hotels,
eating in our restaurants,
and this is a projected economic impact
of $4.1 million coming to our city.
That's the forecast number
from the Convention and Visitors Bureau.
So we're very excited about this tourism boost.
They're gonna be staying in our hotels
and eating in our restaurants,
staying all over town.
We encourage you to say hi to them, ask for a picture.
They are great advocates for their sport,
and they love coming to Huntsville.
They love the rocket when they came here last time.
They love our barbecue.
They love our southern hospitality.
They are friendly, and they want to meet you and say hello,
and we want you to take pictures with them
and post about the races and encourage people to come.
These are the different types of cycles they race on,
and I wanted to show these pictures
because it kinda helps hammer home what this is.
If you haven't watched paracycling before,
it's kinda hard to picture what it is,
but they race on five different types of cycles
based on the athlete's disability or impairment.
These are para athletes,
so it might be that you can see what their disability is,
or it might not be something you can see,
like a back injury or a traumatic brain injury,
but some race, and it's clear.
So on the top right, you see a tricycle.
That's a tall trike,
and that's a US athlete on that trike.
He's a Paralympic silver medalist.
In the middle, on the far right, you see a hand cycle.
That's one that's very low to the ground.
That's an Italian athlete.
He is competing.
The athletes on those low bikes
have some sort of spinal cord injury
or paralysis from the waist down sometimes.
The athlete below him is kneeling in a hand cycle,
and those two hand cyclists, they're powering with their arms,
and they have tremendous upper body strength.
So in the lower center, you see cyclists.
There are lots of cycles on the course, men and women.
And then on the lower left, those are the tandem cycles.
Those are my favorites.
There's two riders on the bike.
The person in the front is an able-bodied cyclist.
The person in the back is visually impaired or fully blind.
And the person in the front is the eyes.
They're communicating with them
about what's coming up on the course.
Okay, somebody's coming up on our right.
All right, we have a hill coming up,
a misting station ahead.
There's the finish line.
Pedal, pedal, pedal.
Those bikes go 35 to 40 miles an hour
because they have four legs powering them.
They're my favorites to watch.
The race venue is Cummings Research Park West,
and you see that big race ring.
That is Explorer Boulevard.
The start-finish line is right
in front of Columbia High School.
That's the checkered flag there.
And then the blue box is right behind Hudson Alpha.
That's gonna be Athlete Village,
and all the tents will be set up there
where the athletes will go and get ready
and warm up or cool down.
And the awards stage is also over there.
That's the one from 2023.
Those are three female cyclists on the podium
getting their first, second, and third place medals,
and a gift that we presented them.
That was Miss Baker.
It was a stuffed Miss Baker doll
from the US Space and Rocket Center,
something that represented Huntsville.
We have something similar this time,
a space-themed gift, but I'm not ready to share it tonight.
So that's the race venue.
I wanna talk about something serious for a moment.
Traffic safety.
It's a week and a half leading up to the races.
These cyclists, in all their types of cycles,
will be training on our roads with traffic.
I want everybody in the room to hear this,
and please share this message with your friends,
your family, your coworkers.
Make sure people know to be careful on the roads.
These cyclists will be using flags,
the hand cyclists especially.
We're putting that at all the hotels
to make sure they have their flags for their hand cycles.
We are urging safety with them,
and we're also urging safety with our drivers.
We're gonna talk with our news partners
frequently about this, our TV stations, our radio stations.
When they do those traffic updates daily,
please hammer home, be careful, look for cyclists.
They're gonna be going to CRP to train.
They wanna learn that course like the back of their hand,
but they're gonna be coming in from all over
to get to the course.
Some have rental vans, some have cars, some do not.
Some will be riding in on their cycles,
all the different types of cycles, so please be cautious.
That will start around August 25th, 26th,
and then the majority of teams get in the 29th, 30th.
But we'll have a news conference with Huntsville Police
on the 26th to really hammer this home.
All right, let's talk about something fun.
Team USA will be here.
These are the many faces of Team USA.
There's 28 athletes on Team USA,
and they're actually training in Birmingham this week
at the Lakeshore Foundation,
with strange para-athletes to get up,
you know, up ready for competition.
So we're actually traveling there tomorrow
to meet with some of them and get some video
and sound bites with them for promotion.
But we're excited to have Team USA here.
Many of them have been here in the past.
We have nine US veterans on Team USA,
and we're very proud of these eight men and one woman.
Four have been here in the past.
Five are new to Huntsville, but they are awesome.
And the Redstone Rocket has been profiling them,
so we're very thankful for that.
But some of these athletes came to the sport
through their combat injury.
Some athletes had, you know, a bike wreck
or a motorcycle wreck when they were home
on rest and recuperation.
But they are all tremendous athletes,
and they compete for their country,
and we love having them here.
The World Champion Rainbow Jersey
is what they're all competing for,
and that will be awarded at our World Championships.
These are two US athletes who won it last year.
But the five colors of that rainbow
represent the Olympic flag
to represent the five continents that compete.
So I have a big ask of you tonight,
everybody in the audience,
if you're a part of a group that volunteers,
if you know of a group,
if you have youth that are 16 or older
who need service hours,
we are asking for volunteers to step forward.
We are almost to our goal on volunteers.
We started at 900 shifts to be filled.
We are now at 160, so it's gotten better
since I turned in the slides.
We're about 160 shifts left to fill.
The shifts are about three or four hours long,
and we're asking for people to serve as course marshals.
They're around the course,
and they're like safety patrol guides.
And they help make sure nothing happens out there.
They call for help if something happens.
They make sure nothing blows in the road.
They make sure nobody crosses in front of them.
It's very easy.
Training is provided, a brief training,
and you can meet 16 and up and do this.
We've been talking with a ton of groups
to get those numbers filled,
and we are thankful for everyone
who stepped forward to volunteer.
We are gonna get there.
We are gonna get our families involved,
but we're almost to that goal.
The main need that we have is for Sunday and Monday,
September 6th and 7th.
So the time trials are the first two days,
the fourth and fifth.
The road races are September 6th and 7th,
and those are the most exciting days to watch.
That's when we wanna encourage the crowds to come out.
So if you're gonna pick a shift,
pick it on the road race days.
This is the course,
you're basically stationed around the course.
You pick an area, and we'll tell you where to park
and where to go in and where to locate.
But course marshaling is very easy.
You don't have, there's no need to have
any prior cycling experience.
You don't have to have done this before.
Anyone can do it.
We have incentives for our volunteers.
These are our two interns who have been helping all summer.
And we're gonna, if you volunteer,
we're gonna put you in a prize drawing
for some great prizes.
If you take more than one shift,
you're gonna get entered in that prize drawing
multiple times.
We're giving away a giant SLS,
Artemis Rocket Lego set,
Corksicle backpack,
restaurant gift cards that our businesses have donated,
a $500 airline voucher,
lots of different things that the community has donated
to make volunteering fun
and give prizes to our volunteers.
I wanna stress that the races are free.
You don't need tickets for these at all.
And we really encourage spectators
on those last two days,
September 6th and 7th, the road race days.
So I did say six, seven, if anybody heard that.
Okay.
But we really want the crowds to come out.
Any day you're welcome.
But September 6th and 7th are the road race days.
So you're welcome.
All the information I've talked about
is at huntsfolkarrowworlds.com.
And we're continuing to update that as we get closer.
The athletes will be arriving in two, two and a half weeks.
And they're very excited to come here.
And we're very excited to host them.
This is gonna be like our own World Cup,
just with a different sport.
So does anybody have any questions?
Council members, do you have questions for Ms. Ayala?
Anyone?
Just want to thank you and thank the chamber for the,
you guys are getting to be professionals at doing this.
How many years have you done it?
This is the fifth one we've done
and the second international one.
But this is a championship.
So they've competed in three World Cups already,
mostly in Europe.
But this is the championship for these athletes this year.
And these are the most elite of them.
So we're so excited.
Wonderful.
Thank you all.
And we hope people will turn out and volunteer.
Thank you for joining us.
And come cheer as well.
Thank you.
All right.
We will move on to the business portion of our meeting.
And item 8A,
matters with outside legal representative.
8A is a council decision on a personnel hearing
for Calvin Haddon Huntsville Fire Department held
on July 31st, 2026.
Is there a motion to uphold the decision
of the personnel committee?
Move to uphold.
Motion from Mr. Little to uphold.
Second from the chair.
Is there any discussion?
Madam President.
Yes, Mr. Cling.
Few comments.
Based upon my discussion that I had
with our city council hearing attorney, Mr. Riley,
I feel that the personnel-
We should clarify it was Dennis Riley.
I'm sorry?
Dennis Riley.
Mr. Dennis Riley.
No relation.
Yeah, no relation.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
With our city council special attorney
that we had for the hearing, Mr. Dennis Riley,
I do feel that the personnel decision
based upon our discussions I had with him
was appropriate in this case.
I do think there were questions that were raised
that warrant further exploration.
There seemed to be areas that weren't totally clear
to the employee and his representative.
And for that reason,
I'd like to request that both HR and legal
review the sections of the personnel manual
that deal with our definition of retaliation
and any employee protections that we have for them
in the manual.
And also to look at directives controlling
how department heads assign special duties to employees
and to HR to give special attention
to deleting section 14.2A1,
which reads the decision to refuse a grievance
by the director of HR shall be final.
That would be deleted.
And then to take the recommendations,
present them back to us no later than
the first city council meeting in October.
From there, we can work on what updates
are needed to the manual.
Let's do this.
Could we, oh, another comment.
I'm assuming that this is an amendment two.
And if that is the case, I will second this.
It would not be an amendment.
This is a request that's being made.
So he's moving to not uphold,
not to even engage in the conversation of upholding,
but then moving to this.
No, this was my, okay, we're having discussion about this.
And this is what I found.
Everybody talked to their discussions
with the city council attorney.
I can go either way.
Does it have to be a formal motion?
Or is it just a request?
What gets the job done is what I'm after.
We have to get this to HR with this time period
and to get it back to the council.
I think we'd like to hear from Mr. Hamilton
for just a moment.
This John Hamilton city minister,
I wanna make sure that I have clarity
because I think here's what I heard
and I wanna make sure that this is what
Mr. Klings intent is,
is that you've asked the staff to review
the specific sections of the personnel manual
that were relevant in question in this particular case.
And so what I'll take from that is getting together
with legal and HR and go through and review those things.
And you asked that by the first meeting October,
we come back with a recommendation on anything
that may need to be updated in the manual.
Obviously that would be that the personnel manual
is itself an ordinance.
And so obviously if there are things
that we have recommended changes
or that the council wants to propose,
that would be an amendment to that ordinance
that is published in the form of a manual,
but it's actually an ordinance that we have to follow.
So what I feel like I heard,
I wanna make sure the staff is understanding
what you're requesting separate
from the decision y'all make right now.
You're asking the staff go do some study for you
and come back to you with recommendations.
I would assume that any request
that a council member makes on this or something like this,
send it to the staff and have it back to us by October one
would pretty much be something we can expect to happen.
Is that reasonable to expect?
Absolutely reasonable for us to do that for you
and come back to you with a recommendation.
And perhaps also Mr. Dennis Riley,
if you could come to the microphone please.
Dennis still over there?
Just to make sure to answer also Mr. Meredith's question,
this would not be an appropriate amendment
because it would not be amending
the decision of the personnel committee.
It's an after action, is that correct?
So we will take a vote then on the decision
to uphold the decision of the personnel committee.
If we could do that first and then
have any further comments about that.
Yes, they are.
So are there any other comments regarding
the decision of the personnel committee?
Hearing none, we'll call for the vote.
Mr. Meredith, how do you vote?
Nay.
Mr. Klein?
Aye.
Mr. Little?
Ms. Watkins?
Nay.
And the chair votes?
Aye.
So the decision of the personnel committee is upheld.
So that's taken care of.
And then Mr.
and your comments are in the record.
Mr. Hamilton has said that he will follow up
both with legal and HR to follow up on the recommendations
that you have made and then report back to council
with any recommended ordinances
or any recommended amendments that need to be made
to the ordinance in the handbook.
Is that clear to everybody?
Okay, very good.
All right, thank you very much for that.
Thank you, Mr. Kling, for your recommendations
because I agree, I think some clarity would be very helpful.
We have no public hearings to be held.
We do have several to be set.
These will, so no action will be taken on these
other than to set the hearings.
10A is a resolution to set a public hearing
on the proposed creation of a tax increment
financing district tentatively named TIFD8
pursuant to Alabama code section 11991.
This is to be set for the September 10th, 2026
regular council meeting.
Mr. Meredith makes the motion to approve.
Mr. Little has the second.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye. Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
This is the first of three TIFD8 items
on the agenda this evening,
but that hearing will be set for September 10th.
10B is a resolution to declare public nuisance
located at 4704 Cabot Drive, Northwest,
Huntsville, Alabama to set a date
for when objections will be heard.
Is there a motion to set for the August 27th, 2026?
Motion.
Motion for Mr. Meredith, second for Mr. Kling.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
10C is a resolution to set a public hearing
for Shoshopakaso Jennings doing business
as Jennings Local Transport for the operation
of three taxis.
This is to be set for the August 27th, 2026
regular council meeting.
Is there a motion?
Motion to approve.
Motion for Mr. Meredith, second for Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Motion carries.
10D is a resolution to set a public hearing
on the zoning of 2.62 acres of land
lying on the north side of Old Monrovia Road
west of Wayne Road to Highway Business C4 District
and the introduction of an ordinance pertaining to the same.
Is there a motion to set the hearing for September 24, 2026?
So moved.
Motion for Mr. Meredith, second for Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
10E is a resolution to set a public hearing
on amending a plat restriction
to remove the restriction requiring compliance
with the front and rear yard setback requirements
of the Residence 1B district of the zoning ordinance
as established on the zoning plat
of the Covert Green Mountain as recorded in Plat Book 2024
pages 100 to 101 of the probate records
of Madison County, Alabama
and the introduction of an ordinance pertaining to the same.
Is there a motion to set the hearing for September 24?
So moved.
Second.
Motion for Mr. Meredith, second for Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
The motion carries.
That brings us to agenda related public comments.
This portion of the meeting is reserved
for persons wishing to address the council on matters
relating to the specific content of items
on the meeting agenda.
You may sign up to speak on the public comments
roster prior to meeting and they have done so.
When called, approach the microphone,
state your name, home address and city of residence.
Each speaker may address the council for three minutes.
Speakers shall refrain from entering into a dialogue
with council members or city staff
and from making comments regarding good name
and character of any individual.
Let me emphasize again that,
and we ask that you please restrict comments
to the agenda item, specifically to the agenda item itself.
Some people have signed up and it seems to be veering
a little bit from the specific agenda item.
So keep that in mind.
We're gonna go ahead and begin with Joy Johnson
because she's the only one that wants to speak
about something different.
So Joy Johnson, the first speaker will be Joy Johnson.
Her subject is 10E, Green Mountain.
Joy Johnson, I live on West Arbor Drive
in Huntsville, District One.
Thank you.
Yeah, I just, again, we're gonna try to change
a plat restriction that we went through all kinds
of meetings and presentations and so on and so forth
to get put in place.
Why do we even bother if then you're just gonna wait
a couple of years and sneak in a change on us?
I don't get it.
Immigrants also came up, so I'm gonna take this opportunity
to say that we have a lot of Palestinian immigrants
in this city and for some reason,
they have not been recognized in their time of need
and I wish we would do that.
Thank you.
We'll now move on to Georgia Hernandez.
The subject is Huntsville's immigrant resolution.
Please remember that resolution was about honoring
immigrants and restrict your comments to honoring immigrants.
Buenas tardes, good evening members of the council.
My name is Georgia Hernandez.
I moved to Huntsville when I was eight years old
from Tegucigalpa, Honduras with my beautiful
immigrant mother and my father,
a US Army Seventh Group Special Forces Green Beret.
Growing up in a military household,
I learned early on what real service
and dedication looks like.
My father took a solemn oath to support
and defend the Constitution of the United States,
a commitment to fairness, justice,
and the protection of civil rights for all people
living on American soil.
That fundamental principle is why I am standing
before you tonight.
While I appreciate the honorary resolution
recognizing our immigrant neighbors,
symbolic gestures are just that.
Our community needs clear binding public assurances.
I'm asking this council to pass a formal resolution
stating that the city of Huntsville
will not voluntarily collaborate
with federal immigration enforcement.
When local...
And as I'm gonna cut you off there for just a minute,
the subject is the resolution itself,
which was honoring...
I'm mentioning that.
Please, but you are straying from it.
The instructions are strict, the specific content...
It's part of the resolution.
It's part of the topic.
You're asking for it.
You're asking for another resolution.
If I can interject.
Please, Mr. Mayor.
There's a person that sponsored the resolution,
that's not a part of the resolution.
I have to disagree.
It's a shame you won't listen to your constituents.
You...
The next person...
That resolution was carefully crafted.
Honestly...
And it's just a gesture.
The people that you are supposedly advocating for
have said they don't want it.
That's very interesting
because I'm one of those people.
We're gonna stop here.
This is not a dialogue.
Mr. Mayor, thank you so much...
You're very welcome.
For bringing clarity.
Thank you for watching all of you.
Thank you, Ms. Hernandez.
We'll now hear from Christopher Lioi,
who's also in resolution 26670.
Is Mr. Lioi here?
My name is Christopher Lioi.
I live in Madison.
My address is on file.
I was going to come up here and thank the council
for passing the resolution honoring the immigrant community.
But out of solidarity with my friend and comrade,
I'm just going to reiterate everything that she said
and really castigate you for cutting her off.
Thank you, sir.
The next speaker is Susan Stewart.
I made my comment.
Thank you.
And we'll hear now from Jeffrey Engle.
Mr. Engle here.
My name is Jeffrey Engle.
My address is correct on the sheet.
I'm a member of the North Alabama chapter
of the Democratic Socialist of America.
And I'm here to thank Mr. John Meredith
for your resolution recognizing the immigrant community.
Huntsville from our founding is built on immigrants.
From British and French immigrants that stole the land.
From the native population here,
I would like to recognize them as well.
And following up by our most historic
of the German immigrants who were brought over here
after World War II, a lot of them Nazis,
to all of the immigrants that have come
in the last several years.
I myself am an immigrant from Arizona.
I moved here farther away from most folks
who have moved here from the Caribbean.
So Huntsville is a city of immigrants.
We call them transplants when they are
from within the United States.
But they are immigrants nonetheless.
So I do want to thank you, Mr. John Meredith,
for recognizing the contribution of all of the folks
who did not grow up here.
So thank you.
And I'm back.
I really appreciate Trey Reilly giving me a phone call
this afternoon allowing me to come back to city council
after six months of demanding my rights be restored.
Thank you, Taneen Robinson,
for violating those rights back in March.
And thank you, John Meredith, for,
so Mr. Engel, your time is up.
Recognition of the immigrant community.
Mr. Engel, your time is up.
We'll next hear from Maria Stansberry.
Is Miss Stansberry here?
We'll go on to Katie Calvert.
Is Katie Calvert here?
Rebecca Sanchez.
And that, oh, Miss Sanchez.
Good afternoon.
My name is Rebecca Sanchez
and I'm in District Four of Madison County.
My address is on file.
Thank you.
I would like to thank John Meredith
for helping us get this passed.
I would like to say my father has been in Huntsville
since the late 90s and he worked from six to seven
as a mason, except on Sundays.
And every day he comes home
and he wonders about his place in this country
and I would like to appreciate for passing that,
passing this resolution to honor immigrants.
And I understand that there was some tenetness
or some apprehension about passing this,
which I do not understand because I think it is only
full of goodwill and benign.
And I honestly think that it could go further.
I think that if you wanted to honor immigrants,
you should pass a formal resolution not to cooperate with ICE
should they become lawless in this county.
I don't think that it's that big of an ask.
Thank you.
That concludes our speakers
and we will go on to the rest of the meeting
and we will hear now from Mayor Battle.
Thank you, Madam President.
If I could ask Thomas Nunes,
Thomas, would you come up to the front, please?
Many of you know Mr. Nunes
because he's up at every council meeting
and he's had every council meeting.
He also works every, what, third, fourth Tuesday night
and works the first and second Wednesday morning,
starting at seven o'clock with meetings,
and he is our planning director.
And he does a marvelous job with planning the city
and does it on a day-to-day basis.
And Mr. Nunes, I would like to present you
with your 15-year pin.
I know you were wondering why you were up here,
but you've forgotten you have been here 15 years
and we want to say thank you.
Thank you for a great 15 years
and thank you for the job that you do every day.
Thank you, sir.
Yeah.
Now, Madam President, the only other thing
that I really wanted to mention today
is we have just finished
with Space and Missile Defense Conference Week.
We had 11,000 people in town, lots of people in town,
and it was a great symposium.
There was not a hotel room open in all of North Alabama,
we were very, very proud of the showing
that we were able to do.
Colonel Icke and Redstone Arsenal did a great job
of putting it together and making sure
that we could represent what Huntsville does,
which is a center of excellence.
I mean, we bring in the best and brightest,
and we become, and we do some things
that nobody else in the world does.
And you could see that at the symposium
over the last three days at the Civic Center.
If you tried to come park downtown,
you probably had a hard time finding a parking place
over the last three days,
but it was a great night for us, a great week for us,
and we are very excited to be looking forward to next year.
So thank you.
Thank you, Mayor.
Thank you, Mayor Battle.
We'll go on with Council Member Cummings
and we'll begin with Council Member John Merida.
Thank you.
I want to thank all those folks who came out
to my town hall this past Tuesday
and informed me of the various issues
that were affecting their individual communities,
and I look forward to bringing satisfactory resolution
to each of those issues that were mentioned.
I also wanna give a big heartfelt thank you to HPD,
the CROs for the North District Precinct, rather,
who were there, as well as their captain, Captain Widener,
who led a wonderful discussion on the value
of participating in the City's Community Watch Program
and all of the benefits that it brings
to the various communities that utilize it
to help keep down the levels of crime
and the cooperation between citizens
in any given neighborhood with the police department,
identifying the issues there,
and also one of the unsung benefits
of being in a Community Watch Program
is you are able to identify, or to identify to HPD
the good characters versus the bad characters
in any neighborhood so that the good characters
are not rounded up with the usual list of suspects.
So there are tremendous benefits
to being in a Community Watch Program
in individual neighborhoods.
If you are not part of a neighborhood that has a program,
please reach out to myself or some HPD officer,
and we'll be happy to give you information
of how your neighborhood can become a part of that network.
And that's it for me, Madam President.
Thank you, Mr. Meredith.
We'll now hear from Council Member Michelle Watkins.
Good evening.
I wanna thank House for Utilities
for coming out a couple of weeks ago.
They had a meeting to talk about the battery installation
in our community.
I wanna thank Wes Kelly and his staff.
I wanna thank Allison and Arts Huntsfield.
This past Friday, we had our quarterly art show
at Cary Hills.
We had a drum line and we had impromptu acts
from community theater, and it was a wonderful time.
Families that came out,
I think they really enjoyed themselves.
Had an opportunity to tour the 9-11 Center.
I wanna thank the staff for giving us a tour last Friday.
Toured early works as well.
Got to learn a lot of things about them that I didn't know,
so that was exciting as well.
Went to the SMD Conference,
and I've had a couple of people ask me,
why did I support the TIF?
I supported the TIF because when you go to the conference
and every hallway, our way space in the Civic Center
is occupied by vendors who support space
in the SMD Conference, who have companies.
I saw firsthand last year, the need.
This year, they had to turn away vendors.
And when you have to turn away vendors,
that means that it's a really successful forum.
And I'm supporting it because if we want to attract
large venues, large forums, large symposiums,
we have to have the space.
So that is why I'm supporting the TIF,
and that is one of the reasons why I like going
to the conference.
I like learning new things that's going on
in space and missile defense,
but at the same time, we have to be able to support them
if we're gonna bring them here.
And not just them, anybody who wants to bring
a major conference here.
Tuesday, we had a meeting in Northwoods Public Housing
to talk about the future of Northwoods
and the university corridor.
And I was really disappointed.
A lot of people did not show up.
So I'm going to have another meeting just so I can make sure
that the residents and the public have input
in this proposed plan.
The Celebrating Education Parade will be on August 22nd.
If you have never been to the Celebrating Education Parade,
I would encourage you to come.
It's a lot of fun.
A lot of schools participate.
Everyone comes together.
The kids have a great time.
We start at ASFL.
We end at Jemison High School.
And once we get to Jemison, we have activities there.
So it's a lot of fun.
Hope you can make it out.
I hope the students had a great week.
Start back to school this week.
Wanna remind everyone, please pay attention
to the school zones and drive the speed limit.
I cannot tell you how many people just passed by me
going about 40 or 50 in a school zone.
You never know when a child is gonna jump out
in front of a car.
And if you're going too fast,
sometime you don't see the safety patrol officer.
So please, during seven and eight o'clock,
well, 8.30 for high schools,
please pay attention to the school zones.
I wanna thank Landscape Management,
Shane Davis, Public Works, HPD, as well as our firefighters.
Thank you for everything you do.
That's all I have.
Thank you, Ms. Watkins.
Mr. Kling, we'll hear from you next.
Thank you, Madam President.
Over the past weekend, I had a chance to go out
to Huntsville High School for Panther Fest
and got a chance to get a sneak preview
and see the upcoming football team in action.
And folks, they are big.
There is one player who must weigh very close
to 300 pounds and be seven foot tall.
And I'm sure he's got a large number
of college scholarship offers
that are already coming his way.
But it was a chance to see things,
and I think we're all getting to that point.
It's hot.
I know it's hot.
I'm out there every day it's hot.
But around the corner, it's gonna start cooling off,
and we're gonna start talking and thinking about football.
And this is gonna be coming,
and we got our high school football teams.
They are practicing now in the heat,
and they're getting ready for fall football.
And it's gonna be a great season.
I had a great time.
Also had a chance to see Mark Russell,
head of the Huntsville Sports Commission.
He was out there.
And again, a lot of great things are taking place
on that school campus.
So I'm excited, go Panthers.
Also a couple capital projects
that I know we're gonna be talking about
when we get into the budget
that impact the district that I'm excited about.
One is the Holmes Avenue Urban Park Corridor Project.
That's gonna be going from roughly downtown
under the overpass at the parkway, further west to UAH,
and then an additional section will go from UAH
over to Sparkman Drive.
This is gonna be a stretched out urban park
with a jogging lane, bicycle path, park benches,
beautiful landscaping, bus stops, low-level lighting,
and it's gonna be something that people can use.
You could walk from UAH, stop, read a book
for a little while, and continue on downtown.
And I think that's gonna be a great project.
A citizen contacted me and told me
that there is a lot of historic significance
along that corridor.
And I would like to ask that the planning department
look into the input that they're gonna be getting
about this historical significance
and see if this would qualify
for coordinating with the state historical division
to see about historical markers being in
to recognize the historical significance
that have occurred in that area.
Again, a lot of history has taken place
in some things we're just not aware of,
but this would be a way to bring recognition to that area.
Another thing I wanted to mention,
I know we've all been hearing from people about the library.
Can we get the water fountain fixed?
I know there've been leaks at the roof.
And I think the library is looking at a plan of action,
and I'm very eager to hear from them.
I know we've had a meeting with them,
and we've heard from them in the past,
but I think we're looking at three options,
just thinking out loud.
Is the library looking at major renovation
at the existing facility that they have?
Are they looking at building a new library at that location?
Or the third alternative,
are they looking at building a new library
elsewhere in the city?
I think there's a lot of interest.
I would hope that despite what the tenure would be,
that there could be some short-term maintenance things
that could be done.
I believe our city facilities department has assisted them
on some of their maintenance needs,
but I think things that the public have a right to expect,
a water fountain working,
making sure the bathrooms are reasonably in good shape,
and of course they're kept clean.
These are things that we want to expect.
We've had great, wonderful new libraries
built in the extreme south and extreme north,
and I think we're certainly gonna be looking
at doing something good in the center part,
but we just need to get that plan of action,
that communication with the city council
and the library board, the director and the mayor,
and everybody all together on the same sheet of music,
and then see what the capital plan placement
would be on such action.
So I just wanna throw it out.
I like the fact we have a good library board.
I know we're gonna be communicating with them in the future,
and I'm sure this will be something
that we'll be able to get resolved.
That's all I have, Madam President, thank you.
Thank you, Council Member Kling.
We'll finally hear from Council Member David Little.
Thank you, Madam President.
I'll just start back with what the mayor
and Ms. Watkins said about the SMD conference.
We spent a little time with some of their board
and some of our friends from the county commission,
and they were very grateful for the TIF
and real excited about the expansion,
and I am too, because like she said,
they've turned away a lot of vendors.
So 36 months, I think, to build the South Hall.
36 months to build the South Hall, can you hear me?
So that'll be great.
And then also like to thank landscape management,
police department, engineering, public works,
and hospital utilities for being responsive
to some citizen concerns over the last few weeks.
And is the Chief McFarland-Leaf, by chance,
is he still here?
All right, you don't have to get up, Chief.
I just, I've certainly communicated with Chief McFarland
over the last four years, but I finally had a legit email
from a citizen to send to the fire department,
and it was about the fire hydrants,
if they'd been serviced, and I just appreciate that.
But I really wanted to point out that after four years,
I finally needed to email you about something
from a citizen, so thanks again.
That's all I've got.
Thank you, that concludes our comments.
We'll move on to the Finance Committee Report.
14A is a resolution authorizing expenditures for payment.
I move for authorization and approval of expenditures
in the amount of $35,721,914.78.
Second for Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye. Opposed?
Motion carries.
14B is an ordinance approving appropriations,
goods or services for District Two
Council Improvement Funds.
Chair moves for approval.
Second. Second for Mr. Little.
Mr. Little, would you like to share with us
what those funds will be used for?
Yes, ma'am.
This is a $5,000 appropriation to,
I guess via Huntsville City Schools
to the Lehigh School Baseball Program
so we can help them get some new uniforms
and equipment for the baseball team.
Okay, any questions for Mr. Little?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye. Opposed?
Motion carries.
14C is an ordinance approving appropriations,
goods or services for District Five
Council Improvement Funds.
Chair moves for approval.
Second.
Second from Mr. Meredith.
Mr. Meredith, would you like to share with us
how these funds will be used?
Yes, ma'am.
$10,000 will be appropriated to the AUM Foundation.
It is a organization that mentors,
for lack of better terminology,
underprivileged young ladies,
and it will go toward their program
called Pathway to Success Program
that does a lot of work.
For them, they will provide some computer equipment,
software, and other hardware type of equipment
that helps them monitor the students
and the students to increase their productivity.
The other is $10,000 appropriated
to the North Alabama Coalition for the Homeless
to support essential document identifications
and documents that are needed for them
to get themselves out of being unhoused,
driver's licenses, social security cards,
that sort of thing that you'd need to take to an employer
or a prospective landlord to help you get out of that cycle.
So that's what this allocation is for.
Very good.
Any questions or comments for Mr. Meredith?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye. Opposed?
Motion carries.
We will now move on to board appointments to be voted on.
We have three that will require four-fifths vote
of the council and we will have a roll call vote
when we get to those.
15A is a resolution to reappoint David Nass
to the museum board of the city of Huntsville
to his current seat for a six-year term to expire
August 13, 2032.
Is motion for Mr. Little?
Second.
Second for Mr. Meredith.
We will do the roll call vote with starting with Ms. Watkins,
how do you vote?
Aye.
Mr. Little?
Mr. Kling?
Aye.
Mr. Meredith?
Chair votes aye and it is unanimous,
so that four-fifths is met.
15B is a resolution to reappoint Joyce Griffin
to the museum board of the city of Huntsville
to her current seat for a six-year term to expire
August 13, 2032.
Is there a motion?
Second.
Motion for Mr. Kling, second for Mr. Meredith.
I will go that way.
Mr. Meredith, how do you vote?
Aye.
Mr. Kling?
Mr. Little?
Aye.
Ms. Watkins?
Chair votes aye.
And Ms. Griffin is approved.
15C is a resolution to reappoint Steve Thornton
to the Vaughan Brown Center Board of Control
to his current seat for a four-year term
to expire August 27, 2030.
Is there a motion?
Motion.
Motion for Mr. Little, second for Mr. Kling.
Mr. Little, how do you vote?
Aye.
Ms. Watkins, how do you vote?
Mr. Kling?
Aye.
Mr. Meredith?
And Mr. Thornton is reappointed.
15D is a resolution to reappoint Lynn Troy
to the Vaughan Brown Center Board of Control
to her current seat for a four-year term
to expire August 27, 2030.
Move to approve.
Motion for Mr. Little, second for Mr. Meredith.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed, motion carries.
15E is a resolution to appoint Vicki Guerrero
to the Housing Board of Adjustments and Appeals
to a seat previously held by Robert Jones
for a five-year term to expire August 22, 2031.
Chair makes the motion.
Second.
Second for Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Nay.
The record show that Mr. Meredith has voted in the negative,
but the motion does pass.
15F is a resolution to appoint Zachary Harris
to the Human Relations Commission,
place two due to the resignation of Tracy Harris
for the remainder of a four-year term
to expire September 30, 2027.
Move to approve.
Second.
Motion from Mr. Little, second for Ms. Watkins.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
The motion carries.
15G is a resolution to appoint Emily Rogers
to the Early Works Museum Board,
place three to the seat previously held by Joanna White
for a three-year term to expire June 26, 2029.
So moved.
Motion for Mr. Meredith.
Second.
Second for Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
The motion carries.
15H is a resolution to appoint Joanna White
to the Early Works Museum Board,
place eight due to the resignation of Josh McCoy
for the remainder of a three-year term
to expire June 26, 2028.
Is there a motion?
Move to approve.
Motion for Mr. Little. Second.
Second for Mr. Meredith.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
The motion carries.
Brings us to board nominations.
These are nominations only.
They will be considered at our August 27th meeting.
16A is a nomination to reappoint Thornton Stanley Jr.
to the Board of Examinations and Appeals
for Construction Industries,
place eight is current seat for a three-year term
to expire September 21, 2029.
16B is a nomination to reappoint Dennis Dean
to the Board of Examinations and Appeals
for Construction Industries,
place two is current seat for a three-year term
to expire September 21, 2029.
16C is a nomination to reappoint Heather Bender
to the Animal Services Advisory Committee,
place two her current seat for a three-year term
to expire September 8, 2029.
16D is a nomination to reappoint Colin Keller
to the Animal Services Advisory Committee,
place five is current seat for a three-year term
to expire September 8, 2029.
16E is a nomination to reappoint Christopher Jason Smith
to the Board of Examinations and Appeals
for Construction Industries, place 16 his current seat
for a three-year term to expire September 21, 2029.
16F is a nomination to appoint Joshua Pennington
to the Huntsville Police Citizens Advisory Council,
place 13 due to the resignation of Brian Webb
for the remainder of a vacant four-year term
to expire August 1, 2027.
And 16G is a nomination to appoint Larry Durham
to the Board of Examinations and Appeals
for Construction Industries, place seven
to the seat previously held by Russ Grimes
for a three-year term to expire September 21, 2029.
That was a lot.
And Mayor Battle, would you like to?
I always miss these and I'm so sorry.
Madam President, if I could, just for the record,
I need to announce the reappointment of Dr. Larry Lowe
to the Huntsville Housing Authority for a five-year term
to expire August 15, 2031,
and the reappointment of Robert Stenson
to the Huntsville Historic Preservation Commission
to a six-year term to expire May 4, 2031.
I'll keep that in mind.
I'll give this to the clerk.
Thank you for getting those read into the record.
Are there any nominations from the floor?
Hearing none, we'll move on.
We will now move on to Huntsville Utilities items.
There are no specific items on the agenda,
but I was reminded that previous to 2020, I guess,
we used to have a representative from Huntsville Utilities
come to the podium every meeting
to give us a report on any issues of concern.
And so we're gonna start that again today,
and Mr. Gertis is here with us
to bring us matters of concern from Huntsville Utilities.
Thank you, Council President.
Joe Gertis, External Affairs, Huntsville Utilities.
We had this conversation internally,
and we had a much more routine cadence
of appearing before council,
even when we didn't have items on the agenda
just to address some of the concerns.
We want the viewing public and council to know
we are aware that people's bills are up.
It is hot.
It is unavoidable, it is weather-driven.
When you have low temperatures that don't go below
where people set their thermostats,
your cooling equipment is going to run a lot,
and that's the biggest.
That and your heating appliances like water heaters and such,
those are the biggest drivers of your utility bill.
Council has asked us over the years,
and we have complied with finding ways
to communicate energy efficiency tips with our customers.
That is a constant effort.
We have never been better armed to do that,
and we are doing that now via our website,
via our web portal, via our mobile app.
We also, our friends in the local media,
give us a lot of attention on those things.
But there are often comments made on social media
where folks worry that we've raised our rates, we have not.
It is just the matter of hot weather.
Your utility bill is weather-driven,
and if you have concerns about your bill, please call us.
Also want to remind the viewing public
that we recently made our home energy audit free.
So if you think something in your home is malfunctioning,
you can call us and set up a time for a technician
to come out and do an audit on your home
and help you identify what those things are.
Then the homeowner, the customer is armed with a way to react to
maybe some high usage that they could avoid
through some maintenance, insulation, things of that nature.
So just wanted to reassure everyone
that we have not raised our rates.
We have no plans to raise any rates in the foreseeable future.
And of course, when we do need to do that,
you will have plenty of notice.
Thank you so much for the time, Council President.
Thank you.
Does anyone have any questions?
Council members, questions for Mr. Gerrides?
Thank you for sharing with us
regarding the free energy audits.
That would be a great service for our community.
We look forward to having you come back at our next meeting
for another report.
Thank you.
Item 18 is legal department items, transactions.
18A is an ordinance authorizing the vacation of utility
and drainage easements between lots 54 and 55,
55 and 56, 56 and 57, and 57 and 58 Oak Bluff subdivision
South Bluff Trail.
Southeast is there a motion to approve?
Motion from Mr. Lerner, second from Mr. Kling.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed, the motion carries.
18B is an ordinance authorizing the vacation
of 15 foot utility and drainage easement,
lot one A block one Linden subdivision 40 Dewitt Drive.
Is there a motion?
Move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little, second from the chair.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
The motion carries.
18C is an ordinance authorizing the vacation
of a portion of a five foot utility and drainage easement,
lot one Hubers corner subdivision 715 Adams Street.
Is there a motion?
Move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little, second from the chair.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Motion carries.
18D is an ordinance authorizing the vacation of utility
and drainage easement between lots 34 and 35 Watson Grand
preserve phase six at McBowlin Cove.
Is there a motion?
Move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little, second by the chair.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed, the motion carries.
And 18E is an ordinance authorizing the vacation
of utility and drainage easement for lots eight, nine,
10, and 15 in the Commons at Trailhead subdivision
Old Gurley Road.
Motion from Mr. Little, second by the chair.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
All opposed, the motion carries.
19 unfinished business items for action.
19A is an ordinance to amend ordinance number 89-79,
classification and salary plan.
Is there a motion to approve?
Move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little.
Second.
Second by Mr. Kling.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed, the motion carries.
19B is an ordinance to amend the budget ordinance
number 25-744 to modify the authorized strength
of the department.
Is there a motion to approve?
Move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little.
Second by Mr. Kling.
Are there any questions on this one?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed, the motion carries.
19C is an ordinance annexing 1.14 acres of land
lying on the north of Countess Road
and west of Jake Jim Drive.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion from Mr. Little.
Second by the chair.
Are there any questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed, the motion carries.
19D is an ordinance annexing 3.07 acres of land
lying on the west of Dupree Worthy Road
and north and south of US Highway 72 West.
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Meredith.
Second from Mr. Little.
And it looks like Mr. Nunez has a presentation for us.
I had a presentation on the last one, nevertheless.
If you wanna continue with business, I'm okay with that.
He's got to earn that pen.
Yes, indeed.
It's the next one.
We really wanna see the presentation.
Thomas Nunez, manager of planning and zoning services.
So this is a request petition to annex
for 1.14 acres lying north side of,
Oh, that was C.
Sorry, 3.07 lying on the west of Dupree Worthy
and north and south of US Highway 72 West.
The property in question is seeking annex
for a commercial retail development.
Any questions for Mr. Nunez?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Motion carries.
Okay, here's the big one.
19E is an ordinance annexing 536.68 acres of land
lying on the east of US Highway 72 East,
north and south of Little Cove Road.
Is there a motion?
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little.
Second from Mr. Meredith.
All right, Mr. Nunez.
Thank you, council members.
This item is east of US Highway 72 East
and north and south of Little Cove Road.
Our petitioners are seeking to annex
is approximately 536.68 acres.
This is for a proposed residential development
for approximately 270 acres are mountainous areas
and shall remain in natural state.
Can you just repeat that again?
So we get that there's-
So of the proposed development,
this is approximately yield 400 to 500 single family homes
and retain approximately 270 acres
in a natural state because of its
slope development components.
That's primarily in the wooded area
that is shown based on the depiction.
So of the 536.68 acres,
300 of that probably won't be developed.
Will be.
Or 300 will be, 270 will be retained.
Yes, ma'am.
Any questions or comments?
Is there a deed restriction or something
that's gonna be on that to make sure
this is what we're told
and something doesn't change down the line?
There are particular actions
being taken by the development team.
The family that currently owns the property
would like to in that action,
see that these areas are preserved.
Through that, it could be a possibility of a deed restriction.
Additionally, there could be possibility
of donations to the land trust,
but those conversations are still ongoing at this time.
Thank you.
So the action before us though is just the annexation
and then we will have those other conversations.
That would be correct, yes ma'am.
All right, any other comments?
I just have a quick question.
I was contacted by my counterpart on the school board.
I'm just curious, well first there was some,
just misunderstanding of how large this is
and it's about half of what she had heard,
so we're good there.
I assume we'll be rezoning this down the road.
That would be correct.
I wanted to give you opportunity to finish your question,
but to answer this strictly as this property,
if this proposal is to annex,
then you'll see in approximately 90, 60 days
that this proposal will come before you for zoning,
where we can get into a little bit more detail
of the proposal and walk through those particular actions.
But yes, upon annexation,
a municipality requirement is to zone the property
for an intended use.
Right, and is it too early to know about
the type of zoning or density?
Yeah, there's a consideration of proposal
for a residence two district for single family homes.
Like I stated, it should possibly produce,
it would be a mixed use proposal.
That would be of some lots at 60 feet,
some lot at 70 and 80 and 100 feet, so larger lot.
So there's a mixture of housing,
which from a planning perspective we look for,
so that there's an opportunity for multiple entry level
or entry components for all those
that are living in a particular area.
So it's just not catered to one action
or one particular consumer at the end of the notion.
But we're excited to see future growth.
This growth will take approximately 10 to 15 years.
There will be other actions
that will come before you in the future.
Okay, great, thank you.
You're very welcome, sir.
Any other questions?
Thank you, Mr. Nunez.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed, the motion carries.
Thank you, council members.
Thank you, sir.
19F is an ordinance to declare property as surplus
and authorize the mayor to enter into a purchase agreement
between the city of Huntsville and API Huntsville LLC
in connection with the North Huntsville
Target Shopping Center.
Is there a motion?
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Mayor, second from Ms. Watkins.
And we have a presentation from Mr. Davis.
Thank you, Madam President.
So no presentation on this item.
We do have some coming, but I do want to explain this.
So as the resolution says,
this is part of the North Huntsville Village project
and we're getting close to closing.
So Target can start going vertical in Home Depot
and out parcels and the other retail components.
So a lot of work has happened, went through plats
and what we've done through the final layout
of this very large shopping center is adjusted some acreage.
So there's regional detention.
We've got the developer API to agree not only to build that
but to maintain that, to have public and private water
going in it, but there will be no maintenance on the city.
So we're selling them that.
And then the out parcels, now that we have the known user
for those out parcels, we wanted to retain those
in the beginning to make sure we had the right retailers
to make commitments to those.
We wanted to get the right development up there.
So the developer has brought those to us
and should you approve this,
we'll come forth with public.
It's at the same rate that you previously approved
what we're essentially doing, adding 12 acres
to the agreement you previously passed.
Should you approve this, we would look forward to close
before the end of the month.
I will tell you the additional proceeds to the city
will be a little over $2.2 million of additional payment
to the city for property.
Thank you.
Questions or comments for Mr. Davis?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Motion carries.
Thank you, council members.
Thank you, Mr. Davis.
We will see you up here in just a minute.
We're going on now to new business items
for consideration or action.
These items will be approved in one motion
unless any member of the council wishes
to remove an item for discussion.
The reading of each item will be waived
unless the council member requests otherwise.
Are there items anyone wishes to hold, Mr. Meredith?
I'd like to hold H,
V.
V as in Victor?
Yes, ma'am.
And Y.
Y as in Yankee.
Okay.
Yes, I'd like to hold C,
E,
G.
I had H down, but John has that.
O,
U,
and I had V down, but John has that as well.
And V also?
Mm-hmm.
And then I would add item M
and item P.
M as in Mary or N as in Nancy?
M as in Mary.
Thank you.
Or Mango or whatever.
So the chair will move for approval and consolidation
and approval of items 20A and B, 20D, 20F,
20I to L, 20N, 20Q to T,
and 20W, 20X, 20Z to AD.
Is there a second?
Second.
Second from Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
We will now take up item 20C.
20C is an ordinance amending budget ordinance
number 25-744 by changing appropriate funding
for various departments and funds.
Is there a motion?
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little, second by the chair.
Do we have questions for this?
So this item is regarding library floor repairs.
We've had lots of questions about the library,
support for the library.
Mr. Hamilton, can you share with us what we have done here
to support the library?
Yes, Council Member John Hamilton, City Administrator.
So what's before you is just a budget transfer
from the 90 capital plan to the library.
They had some flooring there,
primarily on the first floor.
So if you're familiar with that library branch,
there's a tile floor that's in the entryway
and around the desk where you engage with the staff.
That floor needed to be replaced.
We had money in the capital plan set aside
for maintenance issues within the library.
So this is just, they had contracted for it.
We're transferring the funds to them
to pay for that project.
Any questions?
Yes, did you say that was the downtown library?
It is downtown.
Okay, yes ma'am.
Thank you.
Thank you for sharing that.
And then I hope people will take note of what we're doing
just to maintain it and keep it going for right now.
So all in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Motion carries.
20E is a resolution authorizing the mayor
to enter an agreement between the city of Huntsville
and Stillwell Construction Inc.
for the Vaughan Brown Center Playhouse Theater
Seat Renovations Project.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion.
Second.
Mr. Little second by Ms. Watkins.
Are there questions regarding this item?
Yes.
Okay, Ms. Watkins.
I can just ask you the question, Mr. Hamilton.
It says seat renovations.
When is this gonna take place?
If it's passed.
I don't know the exact timeline on it,
but it'll need to be pretty quickly.
I mean, it's part of the ongoing project,
but it's a replacement primarily of the seating
in the playhouse.
Will there be any downtown?
I mean, downtime.
Would it be a lot of downtime for the theater?
There has been some downtime,
and they've managed their rental schedule
around those things.
Okay.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
20G is up next.
20G is a resolution authorizing the President
or President Pro Tem with council
to make written or other submissions as required,
give notices or notifications,
and represent the council meetings as required
by Alabama Code Section 11-99-1
with respect to consideration of tentatively named
TIF D8 on behalf of the City Council
of the City of Humpback.
Motion to approve.
Motion for Mr. Mayor, second by the chair.
Second by Mr. Little, thank you.
So this is the first of two items
we're going to take up regarding TIF 8.
And so Mr. Davis, if you'll introduce this particular item
and then we'll go on to the next one.
Yes, ma'am.
Thank you, Madam President.
Shane Davis, Director of Urban Economic Development.
So council members, it hasn't been very long ago
that you approved a TIF 9 district.
This is a proposed TIF 8 district
and they go in sequential order.
One of the reasons that the downtown TIF was TIF 9,
this proposed TIF was actually proposed
or prepared for or reserved, if you will, many years ago.
When we purchased the property where Eli Lilly
will set up shop here in the next coming years,
you see the logo there where they will be at exit,
Northeast corner of exit three of I-565
and Greenbrier Parkway.
As part of that large private investment
by Eli Lilly of over $6 billion,
what comes along with that,
just the same as we did for Polaris at TIF 6
and we did for Mazda Toyota with TIF 7,
is there's public improvements that need to occur.
And the best way to do that
is through a tax increment financing district.
So what that allows us to do is to take that investment
and use it to capitalize into road improvement projects
and utilities and things that we need to do
to support Eli Lilly, but as I've told others in this area,
it's also to support the existing industry that's out here.
So at exit three, if you've been out there
in the mornings today without Eli Lilly coming,
it's super congested.
We put 15,000 new jobs at this exit in the last decade.
So what we wanna do is what you have done,
you've set a public hearing already
for the next council meeting.
This item that you're looking at right now
or will vote on is to designate the council president
as the representative of the city
and working with our deferred tax recipients,
meaning the Limestone County Commission,
just as we did with the Madison County Commission
on TIF 9.
That is by state statute, that is required by state law
as we start to walk through this.
The next item that you will also take up tonight
is you will direct the administration,
the mayor's office and my office,
to develop a project plan to bring before this body
and to share publicly and for you to be able to review
and consult and provide guidance.
And once that draft plan has been discussed
at that public hearing, then we would then move on
to the Limestone County Commission and present it to them
and then back to this body for adoption.
And then we would move forward
with the final identified project items
to be placed in that TIF district.
What I wanted to do tonight is just very quickly
show you a tentative of what we believe
will be the general boundary.
Should you take up this item and the next item
and approve that tonight, we will then roll our sleeves up
and finalize this boundary.
But generally speaking, we know the road project
and utilities that need to occur
in this general area moving forward, Madam President.
Council members, do you have questions or comments?
Comment.
Thank you, Shane.
Yes, sir.
Really appreciate all your work on this.
And particularly, specifying where the Eli Lilly campus
is gonna be, there has been some discussion in the community
that folks didn't know that it was going
to include that campus.
Sure, yes, sir.
I know I personally focus more on the area south of that.
So I'm probably partially to blame,
but thank you for letting the public know
that Eli Lilly is actually included in this TIF
and they're just not generating the interest in the TIF.
Council Member Brinkley has a good point.
We would not be enacting or asking to move forward
with TIF District 8 without the Eli Lilly project,
just like we did with Polaris with TIF 6
and Mazda Toyota with TIF 7.
That is a known investment coming,
but to win those projects, the community has to make
commitments in public infrastructure investment.
I'm going to keep my dig down deep questions
for the public hearing.
Yes, sir.
So that you can save a little of your voice,
but thank you so much.
You and your staff and planning as well
have just done yeoman's work on this.
There's a great team behind me, sir, absolutely.
Other questions or comments?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed, motion carries.
And then we'll continue that discussion with 20H.
20H is a resolution authorizing the City of Huntsville
Department of Urban Development to prepare a project plan
for the development of a proposed
tax increment financing district tentatively named TIF D8,
which district encompasses approximately 9,054.82 acres,
more or less, in accordance with Alabama Code
section 11-99-1.
Motion to approve.
Second.
Motion for Mr. Maris, second for Mr. Kling, Mr. Davis.
Thank you, Madam President.
Again, this action is you authorizing or directing
the mayor and the administration to develop a project plan
and bring before this body for discussion
and finalization of, and what that would do
is a multiple things.
One, it would define the final boundary.
It would also identify all projects to be performed
or to be paid for within that district
under those future revenue streams
from future private investments.
And we'll get into that.
Should you approve this in a couple of weeks?
Questions.
And the public hearing will be on?
September 10th.
I believe it's what it is.
September 10th, and it will be on that plan.
Yes, ma'am.
Is that correct?
That's when the administration would introduce
the draft project plan to this body.
But this is gonna get you started, so that's good.
Yes, ma'am.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed, the motion carries.
The next item is item 20M.
Well, keep me straight here.
20M is a resolution authorizing the mayor
to enter an agreement between the city of Huntsville
and ACOM Technical Services Inc.
for engineering design services
for Hobbs Island Road Bridge replacement
over Aldridge Creek project number 71-26-BR02.
Chair moves for approval.
Second.
Second from Mr. Little.
And Ms. Martin, the reason I have held this
is there's lots of confusion between this
and the railroad bridge.
And so can you please tell us what we're doing here?
Yes, ma'am.
Kathy Martin, director of city engineering.
So this is a design contract with ACOM
for the full replacement of the Hobbs Island Bridge.
This is the bridge that's just east of the parkway
along Hobbs Island Road.
It's a two-lane bridge right now.
We've monitored it for many years
and it's time to replace it
and it will be able to handle the truck traffic
in that area.
Which will be good news for the folks in Marina Woods
who don't like the truck traffic coming through
their roads there and tearing up their roads.
And again, the railroad bridge is a separate project.
The railroad bridge that collapsed,
that will be handled separately.
This is the road itself,
the road that goes over,
the Hobbs Island Road that goes over Aldridge Creek.
Yes, ma'am.
Thank you.
Anybody else have comments?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
Thank you very much, Ms. Martin.
20, oh.
20, oh is a resolution authorizing the mayor
to enter into a construction services agreement
between the city of Huntsville and Thresh Commercial
Contractors Inc. for the public parking improvements
for the Orion Amphitheater.
Is there a motion to approve?
Move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little, second from Mr. Meredith.
Mr. Wilkinson.
Yes, good evening.
Ricky Wilkinson, Director of General Services.
As you mentioned, this is a construction services agreement
with Thresh Commercial Contractors
for the public parking improvements
at the Orion Amphitheater.
This construction contract is for a precast parking deck
to be installed just east of the amphitheater
and adjacent to the former Tarkog property.
The amount of this construction contract
is $32,950,000.
This will be a four story parking deck
with 924 parking spaces.
Questions for Mr. Wilkinson?
I guess I would for clarification.
It says that it is a parking improvements
for the Orion Amphitheater,
but this deck will be available to anyone in mid city
that wants to use it.
Yes, that is correct, absolutely.
Is this gonna be paid parking
or is it gonna be free parking?
Yeah, no, so right now there are provisions
in the contract and in the construction documents
for future parking equipment
if we choose to add that in the future,
but when it's opened, it will not be paid.
As you're probably aware,
if you buy a ticket to the amphitheater,
your parking ticket is included
with your venue ticket there,
so there'll be no separate controls here.
It'll be open during normal business hours for mid city
for free parking as well.
Is any of that parking money gonna be used
to be in an enterprise account
or to defray the cost of this?
Again, I mean, there's no charge for this.
Okay.
Other comments or questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed, motion carries.
20P is a resolution authorizing
the entered agreement between the city of Huntsville
and Visionary Integration Professionals, LLC
for software to improve cross-department coordination
for zoning, permitting, inspections, and other functions.
Is there a motion?
Move to approve.
Motion for Mr. Lillicum from the chair.
Mr. Musney with us tonight.
Yes, thank you, Council President, Council, Mayor.
This is a legacy software system that is...
Hang on, Mr. Musney, would you just introduce yourself,
your title for the record?
Yes, Alan Musney, Director of Inspection Services.
Thank you, sir.
Welcome.
As I was saying, this is a legacy software
that would include multiple departments,
all involved with development and building.
The inspection department would be the sponsoring department
for this, so this is a legacy system.
It will place numerous existing software systems
that we already in play.
Mainly, our permitting system, which is over 25 years old,
it's really overdue.
We have problems, crashes, as well as implementing
disjunal permits and stuff across the board.
It will increase our abilities to issue all permits online,
saving that, so we'll have a key system right now.
We cannot do that across the board.
So like I said, it would be with multiple departments
up to 12 in divisions of those departments.
So with community development, we're covering this software.
We'll have a system that will be sourced,
and I'll kind of go through this slideshow
here with you right now.
Like I said, the main benefits of this
are outdated technology.
Of course, our current systems are not available
for accessibility and transparency.
We have cross-department use
is some of the main use integration,
but this is just a key point.
We're working with life cycle tracking.
We'll have all of our data together,
which will include easy tasking, cut down on staff
and communications between staff,
which is sometimes hard to achieve during departments
where all of our systems will be mobilized together.
We'll have mobilization between our field capacity
which is all departments engineering,
which currently don't have a lot of that in play.
Inspection will continue.
We'll have our GIS system part of this data.
So we'll track down, we could track our systems
a little bit better, track our developments as well.
Payment system, finance, the legacy
and future compatibility,
also improving other departments
like we can add modules as needed.
But this will cover, generally first up to 150 users.
This will also work through the current process
as well as for any other software integrates,
like I said, multiple department requirements.
Went through the standard RFID through bid net.
We had 21 credible proposals that were submitted to the city.
We narrowed those down to the top three,
of course, I'm choosing.
And the chosen vendor for this selection
went through rigorous, through all the departments
and through staff.
It was directed through our chief innovation offer,
Larry Lowe helped us to guide us through this system.
So we feel like it's comfortable
and chose the right company during this process.
We'll be visionary integrations of professionals.
We have members of their team here also
that come in out of town that was here to represent
if needed, like recognize them as well.
Like I said, overview went through evaluation solution.
We ended up going through, we had a grading system
that was technical with 70 points,
pricing was 30% of that.
So we had a vast majority.
Of course, this software was not the highest
of the other ones we took.
So we took the valuation and chose that
to be selective and make sure we chose the right
based on all the departments input as well.
So, close on selection was negotiated,
any costs or anything like that.
Ligo went through the system very well.
On both sides, ITU supported this as well too,
went through and all the security measures are in play.
VIP contract is here.
This is a three-year agreement.
So this is not one lump sum.
It starts out with a total,
the total valuation of this is noted,
just 1.93, just right under $2 million
for that three-year plan.
Implementation of that and the SAS subscriptions
are based on that, based on a three-year subscription process.
The most, one of the biggest costs, of course,
integrations of all the systems and everything in this.
So this is a, until based on 14 sprints throughout
the process, but it is a three-year program
right now we have for this total.
You can see some of the records,
there's opposing up to 75 records.
It would include automatic, also backup systems,
integration with our laser fish,
it would cut down on some manpower
on stuff like that as well.
So it would be integrated with C click fix,
so that way part of our systems,
we have different systems,
so all of our teams will be able to look at this,
look at data between different departments
and one system based on those,
the addressing is through our city systems.
And then time lock, it says the 18-month implementation
of that in 36 months total contract on this valuation.
Any questions or anything for that?
Questions for Mr. Moosney?
I will make one comment, and that's one of the things
I hear from home builders a lot,
is you've addressed a lot of the questions that they have.
Yes, ma'am.
Where instead of having to go to one department
after another and fill out the same paperwork,
this will integrate it,
sounds like communication will go a lot better.
So this, a lot of work, a lot of expense,
but it will benefit in the long run home buyers
who will be able to get their homes built,
hopefully faster, and go through the inspection process
a little bit more clearly.
Yeah, all this that will be collected
based on those addresses.
So anything for community development,
we had a discourse in years past,
our team could see those in the field
when we're there doing the inspections,
in any department to be able to see all that data
into that one group, group together
into a uniform fashion, so.
Good.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye. Opposed?
Motion carries.
20U is a resolution to authorize the mayor
on behalf of the city of Huntsville
to apply for a U.S. Environmental Protection Agency
a fiscal year 2027-2828,
air programs grant an amount up to $300,000.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion for Mr. Little.
Second from Mr. Meredith.
Mr. Davis.
Thank you, Madam President.
Shane Davis, Director of Urban Economic Development.
So mayor, I mean, city council members,
this is an annual renewal air grant
that our natural resource department applies for every year
to help fund and operate the department.
The amount of grant would be $200,000.
It comes with a 40% match,
which is part of their annual budget
that gets to count towards that.
So it's just a renewal of an annual EPA air grant
that we apply for and have routinely received annually.
Questions for Mr. Davis.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye. Opposed?
Motion carries.
Madam President, if I can ask.
Yes, sir.
What those funds are used for is to monitor
our air pollution program that's required.
Thank you so much.
I should have brought in what the money's used for.
Thank you.
20V is a resolution authorized in there
to execute modification number two
to the agreement between the city of Huntsville
and Skyfire AI Inc.
Motion to approve.
Motion for Mr. Merida.
Second.
Second for Mr. Little.
Who is going to be speaking to this, Mr. Hamilton?
Good evening, council members.
What's before you is a modification
to our existing contract with Skyfire
that relates to our drones and source responder program.
So as you will recall, we went into a pilot program
to operate drones and source responders from a single site,
which is the police headquarters
at the Municipal Justice Building.
But that program is limited to a certain radius
based on safety standards and FAA standards.
So let me just back up and kind of explain
what the drones and source responder program is.
So citizen calls in, calls 911,
they have an emergency at whatever location.
As the program is used right now,
whatever that location is within the allowable radius
of our site there at Municipal Justice,
the NAMAC can launch a drone to get eyes on
whatever that situation is quickly.
Generally speaking, that drone can get there
a whole lot faster than the police can
or other emergency services.
That allows them to actually see what's happening there,
see if there's a hazard,
or confirm that maybe it's a false call
or whatever it may be.
But give to those responding officers
and other, whether it's the fire department or HMZ
or other entities as well,
a sense of what's actually happening on the ground
to make sure that we've got the right resources on the way.
If there's a particular hazard that you need to be aware of,
they can know that in advance.
Because of how large and spread out our city is,
that one site doesn't come anywhere near
covering all the area that we need to.
So what this modification will do
is add three additional sites spread further out
so that we can start providing that service
to a greater portion of our city.
Now that we're past that pilot program
and it has worked well,
this allows us to continue to expand
and deliver the service to more and more of our citizens.
Mr. Mayor.
Are any of these new additional sites in District 5?
So they will definitely provide coverage District 5.
I don't have the map in front of me
to know that the launch point is actually in District 5
because they'll end up covering multiple,
it'll go into multiple districts
based on where the radius is,
but I'll get you a map with the specific sites.
They'll be from municipal facilities.
But I know that portions of District 5
will have that coverage.
I just don't know if the launch site
is actually located in District 5.
Launch site with the radius.
Exactly.
If you can get that to me.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
Ms. Warkin.
What's included in this monthly cost?
So there is some of the cost
is the upfront purchase of the equipment.
So it's not only the actual drones
and the launch equipment,
I think it's also a radar system
that's part of the safety
to ensure that they understand what hazards.
And there's a lot of FAA rules
that kind of dictate how the altitudes
and things like that,
just the way they separate the airspace.
But a lot of the system is related to the safety.
And then in the monthly fee,
there's certain licensing fees
as well as operational costs that go into the monthly fee.
So Skyfire is a local company,
actually does a lot of training for drones
and do these types of equipping
and assistance with operations.
Okay.
At the end of the contract,
were we on the drones?
Yes, we're buying the equipment.
Okay.
So we were on.
Now I would anticipate,
if it continues to be successful it is,
as equipment and technology evolves,
we're likely doing life cycle replacements
of the systems as we go along.
Have you done an analysis to see what it would cost
the city to operate their own drone program?
The specific answer to your question,
no, the way you're asking the question, no.
I have not specifically looked at what the cost would be
to bring these employees in as city employees.
We do have some employees that work in this area,
but right now the cost associated with full-time employees
as opposed to the contract services is definitely,
would definitely be higher.
But I'm happy to kind of go through that with you
if you want to kind of see that and see if we,
as we evolve the program,
we oftentimes do those things where we start out
with on a contract and then as the program grows,
we start turning it over to full-time employees.
And so that's something that we would want to continue
to monitor year over year.
So has drone deployment,
has it reduced officers response time?
Well, what it does is it gets,
it definitely gets our officers eyes
and the folks in the name acts eyes on it much, much faster.
So oftentimes we're getting to a scene in a minute or less
where an officer might be four or five minutes
is based on just based on distances.
It's not gonna speed the actual officers in their cars,
but what it does is allow them to get eyes on,
understand what situation they have.
There's examples might be they were,
they were, you know, the 911 call said,
go to this particular address.
There's been an assault.
And what the drone sees is the person who perpetrated
that crime is now departed.
And they can see where they actually went down the street.
They can vector the officers into the correct location
where somebody might be hiding in the bushes
or those kinds of things.
Okay.
So it's helped them identify
if the offender is still in the area.
Absolutely.
Okay.
You know, we see that often, quite frankly, you know,
I've been able to go and kind of do some after action reviews
with, with name act on particular things.
And you will see where somebody, if they committed crime,
and then they go hide in the bushes somewhere.
And oftentimes that drum sees exactly where they went,
particularly if a citizen is able to,
to give us a good description, maybe a vehicle.
There's been times where we've been able to see the vehicle,
leave the scene and get, get understanding
of what it looks like and what direction it went,
and then get officers going in the right direction.
How long is the drone video retained
and who owns the video?
So we own all of that.
The, the, the retention policies really should follow
the same as we have for body cams.
And there's really kind of,
there's two answers to that question.
We don't retain those videos forever.
Often there's a lot of video gets taken
that has no additional purpose.
And so under state law,
we have certain retention requirements
and then it goes away.
Generally those are about two years.
But if there's one that gets tied
to a specific investigation,
then it gets categorized and needs to be saved
so that the district attorney or whoever wants to,
as something moves into judicial system has,
has access to that.
But, but most of the video,
the vast majority of our video,
whether it's the dash cams or the body cam
or these kinds of things have no, no real purpose.
And once it goes beyond the retention requirements by law,
it would be deleted.
Thank you.
I have a quick question.
Mr. Little.
Mr. Hampton, these are the same drones
they use for crash investigations.
Is that a different?
That's different.
So, you know, so our, our traffic services division,
when they have to, to investigate a traffic accident,
particularly if there's been a fatality or a serious injury,
they'll use those to actually map out
and get an understanding of what happened in the accident.
So they have those in their cars.
It's a separate, that's separate.
We had a fatal motorcycle accident
by our house back in June.
And I'd just seen the demonstration
at the, at the event they had down in the park.
And it was just, you know, bad luck, but yeah.
I was telling my family,
I was like, look, he's gonna fly a drone
around the crash site, you know, and it's really, you know,
I hate that that happened,
but it's cool that we have that capability.
But I was just curious if it was the same.
Well, and so, and there's really two things
that, that ultimately that program is beneficial
to the citizens.
It's obviously always a very unfortunate situation,
but you know, anytime we're having to investigate
a fatal car accident, the road is oftentimes closed
for an extended period of time to ensure that,
that everything that happened is understood
as best as possible.
Those, those drones allow us to measure it much,
much more precisely and get the road reopened
much more quickly, just, you know,
so that we can get back to business.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
I would make one comment and council members,
if you have not taken advantage of the opportunity
to go visit the NAMAC and see how these drones are used
and how they benefit the officers in being able to respond
effectively for citizens,
I would strongly suggest you do it.
It's well worth a look.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
And finally, 20Y.
20Y is a resolution authorized in the mayor
to enter into a project development agreement
between the city of Huntsville and Wonderland, AL LLC
for a new mixed use development at Graham Farms.
Motion to approve.
Motion for Mr. Merritt.
Second.
Second for Mr. Little.
Mr. Davis.
Thank you, Madam President,
Shane Davis, Director of Urban Economic Development.
So what is before you is a standard
project development agreement.
We bring these to you from time to time throughout the year.
And this is for a mixed use residential development
in the Limestone County annex portions of Huntsville.
Before I get into that,
I want to, for the viewers and also for this council
and the members of the public are here tonight,
why do we do these public private partnerships?
So, you know, the city of Huntsville in recent years,
I'd say in the last 10 years,
we've been laser focused on supporting new residential,
but in a way to deliver new housing stock
that provides a variety of processing and amenities
along with new retail opportunities
within those communities.
We've got a growing community, you know,
28% population growth.
One of the things we want is to control affordability
in doing that.
So since that time,
this strategy has produced thousands of new housing units
and it's allowed Huntsville to remain
one of the most affordable metros in the US since 2017.
If you look at the bottom of the screen from 2017 to 2020,
we were the most affordable metro
with a population over a hundred thousand.
And from 21 and 22, we're number four.
We're currently, the last two years
have been the second most affordable metro.
So this strategy is working,
but the key factors that have done that is updated zoning.
You've seen Mr. Nunes come before you
and talk through that
and things that staff has done to strategically allow us
to introduce different and varying price points
without diminishing quality in our communities.
Strategic annexations such that, you know,
we don't get in a position to where
it becomes such a market to, you know,
the list price is only the starting price.
So we're allowing to bring new product in
to keep a healthy real estate market in the community.
Infrastructure investments, of course,
and what you're gonna look at tonight,
public private partnerships.
The map there just very quickly just shows you
in the pink completed projects that the city has some,
in some way participated in.
Some of it may have been just expedited permitting
using our urban development team all working together
a small sewer utility extension
to making road improvements in the bus.
But those are projects that have come for this council.
You've graciously approved those.
We've delivered those to the community.
The green areas show you active projects
where in some fashion,
the city is helping move those forward in a way,
but they come with conditions.
So let's get into the one that you're gonna look at tonight.
So this is Ground Farms.
It's a master plan community
in the Lambstone County area of Huntsville.
So in the yellow box that you see
kind of the upper left of the screen,
you see the project site will zoom into that momentarily,
but this is the 300 acre development.
Mr. Graham and his family are here tonight
along with the developers.
Mr. Graham and I have had a labor love for this.
This is a project that has been
about three years in the making.
I can tell you the ground family,
this project, this property has been in their family
for a very long time.
And one of the things that they said
from the beginning annexing into Huntsville
several years ago is we want to deliver a project
that's not just another subdivision.
So they have procured and been very deliberate
in who they want to enter into agreements
to one, purchase the property and develop it
and develop it in a way that both the city
and the ground family wants to see
that piece of property developed.
And we appreciate that.
So the 300 acre development is a,
we'll get into more detail,
provides multiple price points of residential homes.
We just have one you annex tonight
in the Hampton Cove area that Thomas went through,
same type process we're working with,
with those landowners and developers
to offer that variety of price point
and varying density, not say how many houses
we can just put on a piece of property,
but really create a sense of community
in these developments.
I'll also include multifamily,
a town center style commercial office
and retail center and then traditional retail.
And then also a third retail section
in an area that we refer to locally as Pete's Corner,
but the corner of Moore'sville Road
and Huntsville Brown's Ferry
with what I would call neighborhood scale retail.
So this is a lot of property, it's 300 acres.
It will take 10 years plus to fully realize this build out.
Do want to point to the screen again,
you see where the Eli Lilly project is.
You see all the development that has occurred
from an industry and job growth.
So there is demand for housing in this area.
The green dots you see are active residential communities
occurring in the Western corridor.
The blue box that you see is the new proposed
Huntsville City Schools K-8 school site.
We'll get into more of that in September
before this body as far as land donations
and now we start to move forward with that.
So again, this is the project site.
Again, you can see it's at the intersection
of Greenbauer Parkway, Moore'sville Road
and along the northern boundary of Huntsville Brown's Ferry
Road.
So this overall master plan that would be implemented,
should you approve this development agreement tonight,
total residential lots is 1,050.
I'd like to refer to those as traditional four cell
single family residential lots.
Then there would be an additional 100 lots
and this would be something new to our community.
We've got others that are looking to do this
in other parts of the city,
but there would be 100 lot subdivision or a phase
within this overall 300 acres that what we refer to,
you've heard Dennis Mattson talk about it,
also is a 55 plus what we call active adult community.
So those are four cell products.
So you would go pick out a house plan
and pick out your lot and you'd make that purchase,
but they are deed restricted for age restriction
and most of those come with maintenance free.
The HOA fee, they're mowing your grass,
they're making any repairs.
So it's someone who is at that stage in life
where they wanna travel or they just don't want
a lot of maintenance.
We've had community citizens in different town hall meetings
have said, I came from a place that we had these
in this state.
So we're excited to see that come into this plan.
It will be our first of many, I believe.
About 85 town hall units and then live, work flats,
30 units, that's very similar to you may say,
what is a live, work flat?
Think of Providence, Maine where you've got retail
on the bottom and then residential up top.
Then 630 multifamily units, those are in the two
orange areas and those will be market driven, of course.
The total commercial retail is 255,000 square feet,
about 25,000 square feet of office,
about 125 hotel rooms in that pink area
of what we call the neighborhood village center
and retail area.
I do wanna point out the corner, Huntsville Browns Ferry
and Moore's Road, bottom right of the corner,
that kind of salmon color you see is that neighborhood
retail I spoke about.
So really three separate commercial retail nodes
in the overall master plan.
They've done a really good job, I believe,
master planing this with a lot of open space.
As you can see, a lot of public space through here.
A lot of that was by design, both with the city
and the Graham family and McKinley Homes
in getting to this point.
So that was a lot, right?
That's a really large development,
but I wanna hone in on what happens now.
What is the immediate future?
What I would say the next 12 to 30 months, it's phase one.
And this is what would be delivered to the community.
It's 350 residential lots, about 20,000 square feet
of the town square commercial.
The first of one of the two multifamily pieces
that you saw in orange, 150,000 square feet
of commercial retail.
We already have a lot of interest in that,
one grocer anchor and some others.
So they move forward with this and we fully expect
with your approval tonight,
we'll see that start to really accelerate.
A dedicated dog park, clubhouse, of course,
and then 15 acres of open green space.
Certainly to the people who live in this neighborhood,
but this is a commercial village center type of office.
People are gonna gather in this development.
So that open space is really public open space.
It's not restricted to just the residents
that we call ground farms home.
So what are our commitments?
It's public infrastructure.
We're providing no cash infusion into this.
This is a private development.
So we, one, agree to provide sanitary sewer service
to all three phases.
We would actually do that in a way
where this initial investment phase one,
the sewer would provide the sewer for the entire development.
So we wouldn't come back to council five years from now
or 10 years from now and ask for more investment
in this community project.
Intersection improvements along Greenbrier Parkway.
There's two of those.
You can see the two main entrances that they come in.
And then a connector road between Marshall Road
and Greenbrier Parkway to help spur this town center,
village, office, commercial.
We don't really go in and build roads
or anything for residential.
We ask developers to do that on their own.
This is really to support the activity
for this commercial and office space
that we believe is in demand
and continue to grow in this Greenbrier area.
But as you know, we do not bring you a project
without commitments by the developer.
We ask them to go first and we come in behind.
So before we would go do any of that,
the intersection improvements provide the sewer.
These are the things that this developer must complete
before the city would enact anything in this project.
One, the developer shall have obtained all applicable permits
for the construction of the phase one development,
including going to planning commission and lots
and going through our staff and then getting,
building grading permits through engineering.
And then developers shall have completed at least 50%
of the phase one subdivision lots.
So they're ready for house construction.
So phase one is 350 lots.
So 175 lots must be final platted
by our engineering and planning staff.
They're ready to sell.
At least 20 of those 175 residential homes
must be under construction, fully permitted.
And the developer shall have completed
the initial site grading, completed the building pads
and infrastructure improvements
for the phase one commercial retail area.
That's the area that you see in the salmon pink color.
And then finally, the developer shall have provided
no cost to the city and necessary easements
for right of ways to construct the public improvements.
I just mentioned the sewer and should we need any right of way
in Green bar parkway to put turn lanes in
to allow the traveling public
to actually get into these retail centers
and naturally into the community.
Council members, I'll answer any questions you may have.
Council members, what questions do you have for Mr. Davis?
I would just say this lines up good
with Eli Lilly moving to town.
Right?
I mean, whoever wants to live out there,
they'll have a short drive to work.
I think this is, I've got three or four options for them
to have a short drive to work.
Maybe it's not a short drive.
May look at this one road.
It's a short drive, but it's the short drive
heading south to work.
But the Swan Cod corridor is a short drive
heading north to work.
Oh, I see what you're saying.
But yeah, but you're right.
Because it's not just Eli Lilly,
there's all, I didn't realize all of that was right there.
Yes, but to your point, Mr. Lilly, yes.
And the whole, the timeframe for all of this to happen?
So build out is 10 years?
We're thinking 10, market driven for sure, right?
But a project of this nature,
we've seen build out in a decade.
We don't have a crystal ball that could take 12 or 15 years
should the market get soft or whatever.
But the first phase is very manageable,
certainly for them and certainly for our city,
certainly for the school that's getting built.
This is not, we're not trying to put 3000 lots on the ground
the next 24 months.
350 lot subdivision comes through planning commission
pretty routinely.
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Motion carries.
The motion carries.
And that concludes item 20.
Thank you, Mr. Davis.
We have one item for introduction.
This is introduction only, no action will be taken
and will be considered at the August 27th meeting.
21A is the introduction of an ordinance
to declare a certain real property located
at the intersection of Moore's Mill Road and Vintage Drive
as surplus and authorizing the mayor to enter
into a purchase and sale agreement
between City of Huntsville and Opadan Incorporated.
And again, that will be considered August 27th.
So that brings us to the end of our business agenda.
The next item on our agenda
is second roster public comments.
I would ask that we take a 10 minute break
because we have a lot of people signed up.
So we're gonna take a 10 minute break.
We will reconvene at 7.55.
Thank you.
Take your seats please.
We're gonna go ahead and reconvene here
in just a few seconds.
Very nice.
All right, it is 7.55 and we are going to go ahead
and the meeting is called back to order.
We will reconvene.
We have a lot of people signed up.
And so we will, I ask you if people before you have already said something you were going to say, don't repeat it, just kind of say ditto and we'll go on.
I will call the person who has signed up and then I will call the next person to speak so that you can be ready to come to the microphone.
Let me read the little preamble here.
This portion of the meeting is reserved for persons wishing to address the council on matters relating to the city business, whether or not such items are on the meeting agenda.
Those speaking have signed up previous to the comment period.
When called, approach the microphone, state your name, a home address, and city of residence.
Each speaker may address the council for three minutes.
Speakers shall refrain from entering into a dialogue with council members or city staff and from making comments regarding good naming character of any individual.
The first person to speak is Tamar Ibarra.
Did I get it right?
Well, Ms. Ibarra, if you will come to the and also to help us with time, let's not carry on.
We're just going to keep going.
Following Ms. Ibarra will be Andrew Sullins.
So Mr. Sullins, if you can get ready, please.
And Ms. Ibarra, if you'll give us your name, address and city of residence, please.
So I'm Tamar Ibarra.
I'm the operations manager at Notorious DOG Dog Rescue at 210 Stoke Street, Northwest.
Thank you.
We are a local 501C nonprofit dedicated to rescuing abused, abandoned, neglected, and discarded dogs.
We receive no government funding and everything we do is funded by donations and carried out by volunteers.
I'm here tonight because our rescue has become the default safety net for a growing animal welfare issue that requires a community response.
Over the past few years, we have seen an increasing number of dogs living in homeless encampments, particularly the area commonly known as tent city and the surrounding blocks, which is where we're also located.
This is not about judging people experiencing homelessness.
This is genuine.
Many genuinely care about their animals.
The problem is that we are repeatedly seeing dogs suffer because their owners are unable or sometimes unwilling to provide basic care, even after extensive assistance has been offered by us or Huntsville Animal Services.
Our rescue has provided food, veterinary care, vaccinations, transportation, collars, leashes, blankets, spay and neuter services, and even offered to accept animals into our rescue when owners can no longer care for them.
Unfortunately, our offers of spay and neuter services are almost always declined, allowing the cycle to continue.
What we are seeing over and over again are animals whose basic needs are not being met despite extensive assistance being offered.
From January of this year to July of this year, we've invested roughly seven thousand dollars in assistance.
That does not include medication, supplies, transportation, volunteer time or food.
This turns out to be an average of a minimum of a thousand dollars a month and twelve thousand dollars a year.
These cases we encounter are severe.
We have treated dogs suffering from pyometra requiring emergency surgery, rescued dogs with cords wrapped around their necks, responded to dog attacks and taken in puppies that tested positive for methamphetamine exposure after being found in environments where their owners were incapacitated by drug use.
These are not isolated incidents. They are reoccurring cases that consume limited nonprofit resources while animals continue to suffer.
I also want to acknowledge that Huntsville Animal Services has worked with us and that we appreciate the officers responding to the calls that we make.
However, our current system is not producing positive outcomes in many situations.
For example, dogs are routinely left tied to the fence outside of First Stop, which is nearby us, for hours.
Monday, August 3rd, one remained there for approximately three hours.
When these situations are reported, this particular day at 930 a.m. and 12 p.m. by me, the response is often that the dog has an owner and therefore little can be done.
That raises an important policy question. How is ownership being verified or defined?
Many of these dogs have no microchip, no vet records, establishing ownership, and they frequently change hands within the encampment.
If an ownership cannot be objectively verified and an animal is repeatedly found in conditions that threaten its welfare, there should be a clear...
Ms. Ebarra, I'm sorry, your time is up. Your three minutes is up.
You have raised some really important issues that we didn't, I certainly didn't know about.
Our Director of Animal Services, Mr. Fisher, is here. If you all would like to go...
We speak weekly, multiple times a week. So this is kind of beyond our teamwork.
Perhaps you could arrange a meeting with council members, individual council members at some time, so we'd have more time. Three minutes is not...
Okay, so you would be open to that?
Yes, absolutely. So we'll look forward to hearing from you. Please contact the council office.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you all so much for being here with us tonight, and thank you for the work you do.
We'll hear next from Andrew Sullins. Following Mr. Sullins, we'll hear from Angelica Condry.
Good evening. My name is Andrew Sullins, and I'm a resident at 1410 Wells Avenue, right here in Huntsville.
Welcome.
I'm here today to express my concerns with the proliferation of flock automated license plate readers throughout the city of Huntsville.
These approximately 100 devices create point in time images of each passing vehicle, creating thousands of data points on tens of thousands of punts billions every day, accessible not only to local police but to law enforcement nationwide.
Flock and HPD fact sheets defend this technology by claiming images are merely single points in time, but thousands of data points easily assemble into a mosaic of our daily travel patterns.
These aggregated data points create a system prone to abuse.
Nearly every day we learn of yet another misuse, either nationally or right here in Alabama.
A journalistic investigation has found over 50 incidents in which officers have run thousands of checks on wives, girlfriends, mistresses and personal enemies.
In just the last month, officers in Moody and Springfield, Alabama were fired or forced to resign after conducting searches on their family members.
Flock proponents downplay these incidents as isolated and point to the mere ability to conduct audits as sufficient oversight.
They note that officers must enter a reason for each search, but neglect to mention that many log entries show big reasons such as test or investigation.
HPD says they continue to conduct system audits without any specifics or past findings.
Beyond the risk of abuse, there is also a clear disparity with more affluent, wider areas of south and east Huntsville having limited cameras along 231 and 431,
while working class communities of color in the north and west see dozens of devices deep into residential areas.
My previous commute from Aston Lake Road took me past three separate Flock hubs, while my new commute from Five Points takes me past Nudd.
If this is truly about safety, does the city not want to protect the people of southeast Huntsville?
Proponents point to solve crimes as justification, but we must ask ourselves if the ends justify the means.
If Huntsville stored all of our digital data, would we solve more crimes? Absolutely.
Would we, the people, happily accept the watchful eye of Bid Brother for this trade-off? Unlikely.
I urge the Council to adopt an ordinance banning the municipal use of these types of integrated devices in city limits.
If unwilling, I implore the Council to, at minimum, set a clear legal requirement for quarterly audits with at least a 20% random sample size and termination of any employee found to abuse the public trust placed in them.
I end with a quote from Benjamin Franklin.
Those who would give up essential liberty to purchase a little temporary safety deserve neither liberty nor safety. Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
The next person to speak is Angelica Condry, who will be followed by Mariko Darling.
Good evening, Councilmembers. Huntsville 35811.
And your name, please, for the record.
Angelica Condry.
Thank you.
I'm here again tonight representing Rocket City Roller Derby, but I want to focus tonight on our appropriations application because I know we're coming up on budget season.
I know those numbers are on your mind right now.
We have submitted an appropriations request for $50,000, and obviously whatever amount the city is able to provide would be helpful, but I want you to know what that money would actually allow us to do.
We lost our long-term venue, which was affordable and sustainable for a small volunteer-run nonprofit.
Since losing it, we have been searching everywhere for a solution.
Parks and recreation has honestly been a life support for us this season, and we are incredibly grateful for that.
The basketball season is coming, and we know that we can't depend on those facilities indefinitely.
The $50,000 would help us actually get established somewhere.
It could help us pay the rent and the initial rent in a facility while we get it up and running, purchasing tables, chairs, and equipment we need to put down a proper track and make the space functional for our practices and events.
I'm also actively working on securing a warehouse that could potentially become that home.
If we're able to make that happen, this funding could help us turn an empty warehouse into a functional roller sports facility.
Eventually, depending on what we are able to secure, we could even look at something like a bank track.
We've talked to other skaters outside the area that have told me personally they would come to Huntsville specifically to skate if we had one.
This isn't just about roller derby, though.
We have roller hockey, figure skating, dance skating, speed skating, and other roller sports in this city.
There is a community here. It's just a community that doesn't currently have an appropriate facility.
Huntsville is already losing opportunities because of that.
This year we were supposed to host our annual fall mixer that is six teams worth of skaters coming from across the southeast and even the Midwest.
And it's not just skaters, it's coaches, officials, families, friends, and spectators.
All those people would have stayed in Huntsville hotels, eaten at Huntsville restaurants, shopped here, and spent money in our community.
Instead, because we couldn't secure an appropriate facility, this event is going to Nashville this year.
We also lost the opportunity to host the Yellow Hammer Roller Rumble, a two-day statewide tournament that would have brought four Alabama teams along with their supporters and spectators to Huntsville.
So these aren't hypothetical economic opportunities. These are two events that we are actually supposed to host, and we lost them because we don't have a facility.
When I first came to the city, I said we weren't asking you to simply hand us a building. I still believe that.
But the more I've worked with Parks and Rec and the more I've researched what's available, the more I believe Huntsville needs to start having a serious conversation about a multi-use roller sports facility.
The city has invested in Stoner Park. You've invested in Escape Park. You've invested in facilities for other growing sports.
I think roller sports deserves that same opportunity. So tonight I'm asking you to support our appropriations request to help us get on the path toward a sustainable home.
Because we aren't asking you to build something for one team, we are asking you to invest in a community that's already here, already growing, and that's already shown it can bring people and economic activity into Huntsville.
We just need somewhere to do it. Thank you.
Thank you.
The next person to speak will be Mariko Darling, who will be followed by Kyle Simpson.
Hello, my name is Mariko Darling. I live on Alpine Street in Huntsville, Alabama.
Welcome.
I also want to speak about roller derby with Rocket City Roller Derby. I want to say that we're grateful the city has continued to provide space for our practices and events.
However, the lack of advanced confirmation for gym use has become a serious obstacle.
When we don't know whether we are going to have a venue until close to the event date, we can't effectively advertise, sell tickets, coordinate with visiting teams, recruit volunteers, or build community support.
We understand that parks and recreation would ultimately like us to find a permanent home of our own, and we want that too.
But sustaining our own facility requires us to grow, and growth depends on successful, well promoted events.
Right now we're caught in a cycle where we're encouraged to become independent of the recreation centers,
while the uncertainty surrounding our current space makes it harder to build that support and resources necessary to do that.
This is becoming increasingly urgent as basketball season approaches, when once again we will face the possibility of losing both our practice and event space again.
We want roller derby to have a lasting place in Huntsville's recreation community.
We want to grow our events, bring people together, and eventually establish a home of our own.
But to get there, we need enough stability to build that future.
Thank you.
We'll now hear from Kyle Simpson, who will be followed by KMP Carroll.
My name is Kyle Simpson.
I live at 187 Heritage Brook Drive in Huntsville.
Thank you.
Good evening, Madam President, Mayor Battle, and members of the City Council.
I'm here to respectfully ask for your help restoring my access to the Huntsville Tennis Center, a public facility owned by the City of Huntsville.
I worked at the Tennis Center for about three years while I was in high school, and in 2023 I was terminated for not completing my closing duties properly.
I accepted that decision and moved on.
However, I have never been accused of any misconduct beyond that, and I was never told I was banned from the facility or prohibited from returning as a member of the public.
Shortly after my employment ended, I filed a complaint with the Alabama Department of Labor concerning my handling of alcohol while I was a minor.
I did so on the advice of my parents because I believed it was the appropriate way to address my concerns.
I took a break from tennis for about three years, and a few weeks ago I decided to start playing again.
For four consecutive weeks, I used the Tennis Center without any issues, and I even had my racket restrung there.
Then on July 29th, when I returned to pick up my racket, I was met at the front door by the managing director, Jock Simmons, who was also my former supervisor.
As I entered the facility, he told me verbatim, get out. You do not get to file complaints against us and play tennis here.
I left immediately. I did not argue or create a disturbance. I paid all my fees, and I have not caused any issues with the facility or its management.
To this day, I still have never received a written trespass notice, never been informed that I'm banned from the facility,
and never been told that I violated any rule as a patron of the Tennis Center.
I'm not asking the Council to punish anyone. I'm just asking for its fairness and clarity.
If there is an official policy that justifies excluding me from a public recreational facility, I would appreciate knowing what it is.
And if there isn't, I respectfully ask that my access to the Tennis Center be restored so that I can continue playing the sport I enjoy at a public facility that serves our community.
I would just like to say I've already taken this up with Parks and Rec, and they said it's outside of their scope.
I spoke with my city representative, and he recommended I come to this forum and take it up with you guys.
And I would just like to thank all of you for your time and consideration.
Thank you, sir. Thank you.
We'll now hear from KMP. It says KMP Carol. Thank you.
And we have a few more questions for you, who will be followed by Kayden Helbling.
Good evening. KMP Carol, 15715, Coach House Court Northwest.
Very good. Thank you.
This is my first city council meeting, and I wanted to know what rules are utilized for this forum.
Is it Robert's Rules?
The three minutes, the three minutes are yours.
I do understand that, but I also, I guess it's my first meeting.
Is this normal? When did life change where you can't come in and ask questions and have you answer me?
I don't know if it happened during COVID or if it's just because there have been other incidents that have possibly occurred.
I don't know, but I'm just trying to find out more about my city.
And this is the first time I'm doing so. And so I did. I want to find out what the rules are.
I can't bring up a motion or ask all questions.
So can anybody answer that question?
Ma'am, this is not a time for dialogue. If you'd like to meet with one of us afterwards, you're welcome to do so.
Okay. Thank you so much.
We'll now hear from Kayden Helbling, who will be followed by Victoria Kuzniastova.
Good evening. I'm Kayden Helbling, a Huntsville resident.
I'm the one who has been making the FLOC records requests. Other speakers have mentioned here in recent months.
Eight months ago, I asked the city for three administrative records from its FLOC license reader system.
The log of the searches run by city users, the log of outside agencies searching Huntsville's data and the data sharing settings.
I didn't ask for video, not case files, just the usage logs.
Records, the state's own LPR rules require to exist precisely so the public can tell whether a surveillance system is being used properly.
Over those eight months, the city changed its position four times.
First, a blanket denial, then an estimate of roughly $1 million, a number they reached by treating a single spreadsheet export as 1.7 million printed pages.
Then a claim that the electronic version of the files is impossible, even though FLOC's own published guide walks agents through downloading these exact logs as spreadsheets, a guide I sent them.
And then on August 3rd, I received a final denial.
The city now says there is no difference between the oversight logs and the license plate data itself.
And that even though it can produce these files electronically, it doesn't have to.
My only remaining option, they told me, is court.
Meanwhile, Blount County, Alabama, has the same Open Records Act, same records, and it gave a complete FLOC audit log to a newspaper this summer as one spreadsheet in about two months.
The same thing that Huntsville says would cost me a million dollars.
That Blount County log also showed exactly why these records matter.
96% of the searches had no case number attached, and nearby in St. Clair County audit logs are how one officer was terminated and another resigned this summer over unauthorized searches.
In one case, searches of the officer's own family.
These logs are not anti-police.
They are how misuse gets caught.
The CGS standards the city brought up in my meeting with them require this logging for exactly that reason.
Every FLOC item this council has passed went through unanimously, mostly on consent without discussion.
Those contracts auto-renew unless someone acts.
I believe one window is as soon as this fall, and the master agreement comes up in January.
And the council doesn't have to wait.
The MOU allows termination for convenience on 90 days notice.
A couple weeks ago, Council President Robinson suggested the city share its usage data more broadly, and Councilman Meredith announced a town hall on FLOC.
I welcome both.
And I ask a simple.
Before anything renews, put the system on a public agenda with the actual usage data in front of you, and make your decision and keeping it on and keeping it an on the record decision, not a default.
Thank you.
We'll hear now from Victoria Kuznetsova and then from Paul Stansberry.
Isn't this Kuznetsova here?
We will then go on to hear from Paul Stansberry, who will be followed by Melissa Robinson.
Mr. Stansberry here.
We will then go on to Melissa Robinson.
Is Miss Robinson here?
James Qualls.
Gloria Vergara.
Is Mr. Vergara here?
Robert Pope Jr.
Carlos Cole.
This looks like, ooh.
Dion Pope.
I may have that wrong.
Vanessa Martin.
Ashley Wilson.
Angela Somerset.
We have a winner.
Good evening, counsel.
Good evening.
My name is Dr. Angela Somerset and I reside in Chalkstone Street, Huntsville, Alabama.
Welcome, Dr. Somerset.
This evening, I basically have a question based on a prior city council meeting that occurred on May 28, 2026.
Our director of finance, Miss Penny Smith, came before the council and she stated that Huntsville Utilities pilot payments,
which stands for payment in lieu of taxes for the electric side that's based on assets, had a deficit of $4 million.
To date, I don't know what that means.
She did say that it was based on a tenant change.
So I would like to know at some point who is that tenant?
What is that tenant?
But let me tell you why it matters.
For many of you in the room, you know that I am an advocate about the utilities.
We have all experienced Huntsville Utilities.
But unexplained deficits erodes the public's trust in the utilities management as well as potentially the council's oversight.
Our councils vote for board members.
I have never seen a board member come in to ever explain any deficit.
And although those boards are there, they still are elected by our council.
And on August 25th, there will be another election for three of our council members.
I have asked now for years to make our utility company more accountable and transparent in terms of those books.
And their ultimate goal is to try to merge gas, water, and electric.
If we are not getting answers on $4 million deficits in the middle of the year based on assets,
something is definitely wrong.
So my concern, I've stated, but what I would like is a specific itemized accounting of that $4 million gap.
Not a general statement, not someone that comes in and just spreads over it.
We need to know as citizens because we own Huntsville Utilities.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Somerset.
We'll now hear from Moses Eben, who will be followed by Alex Kimion.
Mr. Eben here.
Ms. Kimion here.
And Ms. Kimion will be followed by Chad Chavez.
All right.
Yeah, you know, I thought I had more time to pull my statement up before a bunch of people didn't show up.
Hi. Good evening. I'm Alex Kimion.
My address is on file.
I live in District 3.
Okay. So I'm not sure what happened, but I looked at the minute or the agenda for the this meeting last night,
and it had the minutes from the budget work session on it.
When I looked at it today, it did not.
So hopefully I'm not being really naughty like mentioning that.
And I was going to comment quite a bit on the minutes from that budget work session because there were comments about the library.
But, Mr. Councilor King, you actually addressed quite a few of them earlier.
So I'm going to blow past a bunch of those.
Thank you, though, for clarifying and President Robinson as well,
the funds that are going towards the downtown library to help kind of spruce it up a little.
But I do still want to stand up for the library board a little bit.
This is the part where I should say that though I work at the library, I do not represent the library in any way.
I do not speak for the library as an institution.
But I still want to stand up for the board because there were some statements made in this work session that sort of implied that the library board is like withholding our salaries and stuff.
So one of the statements that was made or from the minutes, it's not a direct quote, but President Robinson said she had somehow understood they, I guess the library, worked with the county.
But this was with the library board concerning salaries as well as decisions regarding the building were a library concern.
The implication being that once the money is in the board's hands, you know, obviously it's up to them to decide salaries.
And that's true. But what we haven't mentioned tonight, except kind of obliquely, was an acknowledgement about the rising operation costs, including utilities,
which, while they may not have increased this year, they did increase last year, along with water, sewage and everything else in the ballooning population of the area.
I mean, every meeting we're here, we're annexing, we're talking about folks.
Huntsville is in Limestone County now. I didn't even know that.
I did not realize Huntsville City is in Limestone County.
So that's two counties now that the Huntsville Madison County's library serves.
Costs everywhere have gone up and somehow it falls on the library to conjure this money.
So anyone who knows me knows that when I smell a rat, I go hunting for it.
And I have no reason to believe that the library board was lying to us when they said that operation costs forced them to pause cost of living raises, tighten budgets and reduce staffing hours.
I have every reason to think they're doing their best in these incredibly trying time for libraries.
And I think they can continue to do more and more for now two counties worth of service population if they are granted adequate funds with which to make these decisions.
The fact is we don't live in a vacuum.
You can give them, we can give the board a certain amount of money, but if all the costs are going up and our cost of living are going up,
I mean, I work 40 hours and live paycheck to paycheck and nobody should be living working 40 hours and living paycheck to paycheck.
Nobody. And I'm a manager.
So thank you.
Thank you, Alex.
We'll hear now from Chad Chavez and I believe he is our last speaker.
Hi, my name is Chad Chavez.
I live at 7512 Club Field Drive.
I wanted to speak about flock cameras initially, but previous speakers have covered this pretty well.
But I did want to address the concerns about the reasons the city's given for denying audit requests.
I also requested audit logs from the flock database acts tracking flock database access through open records requests.
And they were denied under investigative privilege the same way the city has denied body camera release in the past.
Despite these being pre-generated reports in flock meant specifically for auditing purposes.
Now, my preference is that these devices are just not deployed.
But barring that, heavy oversight is needed because these databases can make it easy to stalk unsuspecting victims,
to track peaceful protesters, or for federal law enforcement like ICE to follow immigrant communities like the ones Mayor Battle thanked earlier this meeting without a warrant or even without cause.
To demonstrate the need of an actual council rule instead of vague promises,
I did want to address the response to public safety policy and procedure recommendations previously put forward after review of violence against civil rights protesters here in Huntsville.
The then police chief promised that policies would be updated and posted through Power DMS.
So that that would be the live version both that the police department and citizens could view as those policies rolled out.
That is still listed on this city's website.
If you click through to the Power DMS links, that's now a 404 error.
So we're no longer updating these policies that were promised after this previous review.
We'd be able to see they'd be kept updated.
Similarly, there was requests in those questions for data regarding crime statistics across the city.
And the promise was made even though we couldn't get specific data that we would get annual reports that gave that information.
It's August 13th and we still don't have the newest stats.
And so I think that this shows a continuing problem with these long delayed reports.
And specifically with concerns regarding internal affairs and when those are being resolved, we're going a full year,
18 months if you have an incident early before those are getting reported, much less anything that can be followed up with by the council.
So again, I think that promises were made by this council by people who were either on this council then or serving in HPCIC at the time that these policies would be made public.
And again, we just continue to see that without actual statutes, we're not going to get transparency from HPD.
And so I look forward to the forum. I ask that you pass something.
Thank you, Mr. Chavez. It's good to see you again.
Mr. Meredith, are you still having your meeting on September 16th?
Yes, it's actually going to be a forum and it will be held here in council chambers at 4 p.m.
Obviously, maybe not obviously, but the public is more than welcome to come.
We'll be here till hopefully your last question is asked and answered.
Thank you. Are there any other business?
Do we have a motion motion to adjourn? We are adjourned. It is 826.
Thank you all for coming.